[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what is going
[Music]
xerox is no one what's going on d nasty
what's up
ksi what's going on brother what's going
on how are you
matter of fact turn myself up a little
bit okay okay okay
actually okay
over the music okay okay okay okay yeah
i can turn the music down a little bit
we got
the beat rocket
thank you sir appreciate you
monkey what's up what's going on danger
all right you got [ __ ] awesome okay
that many things
yeah yeah that's soprano that's what's
up
that's that's official
gaming fire what's going on i don't know
what you wrote that was attractive but i
guess you made it right
abel what's up ford say all right forte
i'm abandoning you right now
your boy did not do what we talked about
we was on the phone and i said i was
supposed to do something i got caught up
and then your boy threw that halo on it
was over it was over
so it's still we're still in the i'm in
the lab with the setup i'm in the lab
i said i was gonna
[Laughter]
i had to set my vr up first man that
took like that that took like two votes
but get that camera up again i gotta
level up the attic i gotta level up it's
in the box you'll be happy to know it's
in the room now
but anyway
[ __ ] you what's up we're gonna get
everybody in the room regular old school
throwback
lord's day with just the round we try to
do that once a month take a little bit
off my plate obviously we get a lot of
guests and not that we don't want yes
you know it's a lot you don't need
preparation and everything like that
sometimes you gotta you gotta hang it
you gotta take it to the essence just
with the lords
they'll say you can't have a guest all
the time plus it really helps everybody
out
so look
we're gonna
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatically i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
[Music]
say that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start it regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
it i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample
[Music]
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i
[Music]
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making
[Music]
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch so many snacks
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for addict if i
can imagine this cooler give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty ain't not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares if you fly
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
to the iron laws podcast llc and also
the lords of gaming.net episode number
227 it's another glory sunday we're back
at the round table on the lord's date
and today we've got halo infinite big
team battle
game past 30 million
sony studio acquisitions tgs overview
and oculus quest vr to discuss so we're
going to get right into it so let's
introduce the four horsemen of gaming
those original lords of the realm here
at the round table no guests today
my co-host with the cole most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh we got a
got a good show for you guys today man
we got a good show for you guys tonight
yes sir yes sir what you've been playing
sir
i can't talk about what i've been
playing
oh shout out to monkey up on facebook
watching us right now he said look at
you yeah you said look at you hearing
some devil dogs sell the face oh thank
you so much i was talking about your own
money and i know your ears is ringing
yes
no doubt
in the building what's going on
no doubt and oh so we got uh looks like
we got somebody else we got smitty smith
with well
salutations lords in chat the industry
will make room to be they better put
respect on iop the book of acts thank
you so much
so that's been pretty much it besides
your undisclosed game sir
i played a little bit of the halo uh
big team battles but
we got a topic about that so i don't
want to go too much into that no doubt
no doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bank my man loris off how we
doing sir i'm doing pretty good very
good actually i got to go out yesterday
apologies we're supposed to have a you
know a venom night out but i had to
cancel because i forgot i watched it
my niece is uh my niece turned 16 and i
on friday
so of course i was working so i couldn't
see her so
yeah i'm about to ask it i was about to
say that i ain't know how to say it
right yeah
he didn't know about how to say quincy
yeah
she uh so we just thought our wife and i
took her out yesterday uh to just
basically buy whatever you want and then
we took her out to dinner so it was good
to hang out with her and just sort of
you know
i can't i just remember when she was
like you know this
she's 16 it's crazy
i only met her when she was a baby yeah
that's kind of crazy that's kind of
crazy because you look now it's like who
are you
venom was pretty decent though yeah it
was actually okay
we're excited for next week we're gonna
watch it next week and
we'll probably let's try to get together
and do a roundtable review i got to take
my sons to see that
because uh dante asked for it and i um
invited david to go see it as well okay
we're gonna have uh a guy's night and
guys night out that's fantastic then i'm
gonna take them to a fine dining
experience
okay okay
no no no no no
oh sorry i'm sorry this is more boozy
than that no no no no i'm talking about
no it's not bougie first of all the
blondes closed too much
they're drinking they drinking fruit
punch
wait a minute so
david's a grown man
david's 21. the oh man oh it's
that's another one i haven't seen since
he was this big exactly um but also he's
on xbox
so okay the best thing is you know we
all connect so sometimes if they see a
lock party it's just me my son's you
know playing some pub g [ __ ]
nice i love my kids because they like
pub g
the man who got [ __ ] in the chat said
no burgers no no no bad guys
[Laughter]
uh nothing on my consoles because i
haven't really been around but um no
gaming lately you know
it's been tough but there's been plenty
of castlevania advanced on my switch
listen
them castlevania games are amazing and
the thing about it is that none of them
look as good as symphony of the night
because they're gameboy advanced games
but the gameplay is all there right all
that metroidvania goodness is there so
i'm i'm going crazy for that and then on
friday i get metroid yeah ah bro
metroidvania's
you know you know me and me oh yeah
that's your job that's it that's my bag
so um the only thing i was able to do i
sat down and watched the majority
of the many saints of newark the the
sopranos movies
i haven't finished watching it but to
this point i'm not particularly
impressed it feels
it like the the the actor that plays
dickie maltesanti so christopher's dad
he's doing a very good job
a lot of the other characters to to see
them in their young form
it really they feel like caricatures
like they feel like young actors trying
to mimic what the other actors did in a
way that feels kind of forced sometimes
actually
kevin feige didn't pick these guys yeah
exactly kevin feige did not did not do
the casting on that because like for
instance like silvio the dude who plays
silvio in weird ways almost looks older
than steven van zandt
so it's like it's just weird and it just
feels like they're trying to mimic
something that's not quite there i will
say though uh um what you call it james
gandolfini's son
yeah
you could tell that he's not really an
actor there's some parts that it feels
like he's you know he's kind of learning
how to read lines or whatever oh drunken
ninja on your head
you cap it hard that movie was fine nah
you oughta you bugging
into the situation because he really
looks like his pocket he really does
look like his dad
and there's this point you see like he
feels genuine right he's just you know
he's not a seasoned actor yeah he's an
officer one second michael santiago when
you get to him we got a
he actually message retracted his chat
but all right he's got what he said
afterwards so if you want to get okay
real quick okay no doubt so yeah so that
was it for me just that was it for me
and whoever's capping for that movie
y'all bugging um
michael santiago
today yeah i mean definitely give it a
watch you know it was fun to to see
those characters back
um
let's see michael santiago five dollar
super chat and then
the message i got it yeah
sorry i lost my super chat message thank
you to king for saving me money on
scarlet nexus and waiting for it to come
to gay fast also shout out to lord cogg
for having the best intros in the game
oh salute
it's the lord's day yes it is tony
bryant says you're right also as far as
the uh soprano giant thank you italian
clowns on twitter shout out to clowns he
agreed he felt like really older he said
his voices see his just laughs seem
forced or something somebody would say
like it but i've watched um that's squid
games
oh how is that
it's correct because somebody told me
that i must watch it and i'm getting
ready to start to watch it next i have
one more movie that i have to see first
and that's the sopranos movie and then
i'm going to jump right into that on
another note i finished death note at it
so i really didn't like how it ended
because i love light there we go
so that's video i love how it ended yeah
that's it that's it so on death note you
you finished the the anime right though
yes yes okay now anime is 37
crazy episodes
now go watch that crate that horrible
movie first i saw the movie first that's
what forced me to watch the anime and um
by watching oh get to my entrance
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access game
the prophet of xbox
where's the schwabe
oh man do you bring the swami yeah
you was like
now i'm waiting for it
why are you talking i just go over it
sorry
king of the statues there's nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing a whole lot better than last week
there's so much stuff going on so much
moving and shaking that's going on in my
life is kind of crazy
but at the same time i found peace and
zen
and i i must say peace is then is
delicious
you know it tastes like it tastes like
that cake when you go into the store and
you see it and you purchase it and it
tastes like how it looks
yes i like piecing zen
i got a couple of statues coming in this
week king of the statues is a little bit
late like i said it's so chaotic life um
this week i've been doing raids sorry
luca for what happened in that raid i do
apologize
well luca has her vex so anytime luke is
in a raid with us doing you know vote
the glass she's helping out right and
she's doing her part she's doing the
most she's doing everything and we had a
situation where she didn't feel a
certain character that was added to the
group oh
well what a double joke
what's crazy is the individual messed up
twice and then i grabbed the relic right
right so every time we go inside the the
shadow realm i don't give a hell i don't
give the hell if we on venus on mars
yeah i'm grabbing the relic yeah you can
shoot the stuff yes i'm grabbing a
relative i'll heal you i'll i'll make
you see again really great so i grabbed
the relic and i'm killing the the the
gatekeeper that's in the middle yeah
right killing keeping us in the middle i
go to hop over but i hit my trigger
button by mistake and slid down
right so the individual wanted to make
oh your mess up was crazy different than
my two mess up i don't know i don't
really know how this is going right here
so you know how to blame this yeah
so it went left it went left no but we
finished it we got it done um nobody got
a vex um that kind i think bungie has to
look at that yeah six people going to
raid
one person should get a vex yeah they
got to work on uh it's still an issue
they said they fixed it it's called the
uh drop rate protection it's supposed to
be every time you do the raid and you
don't get the raid weapon the percentage
is supposed to go up but shout out to
sir taz we got him in a clan he did like
40 something classic but but that was
before they fixed it though
for my understanding this is recently
that i don't i mean they said you know
he just got it now yeah but they said
they've been fixed it and they stole it
oh wow
20 players and i still ain't got it yeah
maybe maybe it's with that raid they
never fixed it maybe because i remember
that the issue was with deep stone [ __ ]
yeah i swear it's people that got the
eyes of tomorrow they're the ones that
got screwed and the ones that that got
it like really early they're the ones
that haven't got the vex and the ones
that waited really long to get the eyes
they're the one getting the facts first
but i got mine so i'm good
when i say this is another language
we know since that maddie flames
are we talking i'm quitting
maybe like i don't know what you said
but yo
it sounds like english sounds like fire
dudes don't want to hear it so okay
the dog said probably they said
i'm happy to see you
everybody throwing up time
there's a
game pass went nuts this month
and they went nuts this month on um rpgs
yeah i wasn't expecting it so i watched
the um excuse me tokyo game show yes and
then watching the tokyo game show
i didn't know they was going to go so
hard for the eastern market
don't go too crazy no no no no no no no
i'm not doing that like that um but i
downloaded a whole bunch of stuff
because of that because i went and
looked at game pass before scarlet
nessus
again phil dominance maximus are really
expensive and you will always put
respect on his name
because you dudes haven't put i know i
go to some people's uh chats uh i'll go
to p people podcasts they don't want to
say the full name
about that why that bother you say the
full name you know why you don't want to
say the full name because you don't want
to bend the knee but you bend the knee
as soon as you agreed the game passed be
honest with you
to be honest with you there'll be
sometimes we forget the whole name
no king make sure we say the name
make sure like the king king will hit he
will be like
i don't even remember the full name
right now
i can tell you an easy way to remember
it he's dominating maximally golden oh
oh oh we got balls okay
we got okay this is a premium situation
he's dominating the situation
to the maximum and he's doing it golden
like he's shining
so is
dominus maximus aurelius aurelius means
golden if you guys don't know go look it
up all right so i go to game pass yeah i
download marvel's avengers again because
i don't
i deleted it shout out to 140 gigs right
though what's up with that jesus christ
i purchased well i didn't get i didn't
purchase that game somebody gifted again
to me and forced me to play it yes
but i i downloaded it to play um black
panther
and then um also to show square enix
where you need to be
all right so
all right so astoria ascending oh the
sides
i downloaded that didn't touch that yet
scarlet nexus downloaded that
um
mighty goose
this is where i gotta talk about all
right let's go let's get right all right
mighty goose
if you ever played um
metal slug okay from from neil oh yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah all right so
imagine
the best of neogeo's metal slug
put into one game where you got a goose
that can honk
while he's fighting he's shooting
and it's like the best of the 16-bit
32-bit slash era okay
and it's it's so much fun it's like a
shoot it's just a shooting wow
you know it looks it looks gorgeous man
what's my nose mighty
this is what stopped me from going to
scarlet nexus automatically because i
put both of them in the download but
goose downloaded first so you hit the
goose up i hit the goose and i'm like yo
the boost is crazy
i'm looking at it right now yeah that's
that deal that's that art style yeah
yeah so they do things now that we
couldn't do back then right right and
and you know the ssd moves fast
what is going on with this awesome like
it's awesome it takes all of the metal
gears all of them yeah it puts it all
into one remember the first one we
didn't really do a lot of things it does
this this is so fantastic for anybody
that's looking for a game pass game
check this out um then i got on scarlet
nessus scarlet nexus reminds me
of well it's it's a japanese rpg yeah
for sure
true and tried and true
i love the voice acting i love the fact
that it feels like a whole anime that
i'm playing
it's it's
it's so good the fact that i played it
for free
um i want you guys to stand up all you
guys that held out and listen to me
listen to me
don't pay for nothing that you see on
the shows if you see it on the show
don't pay for it
just wait for that game fast play your
games wait for it man because i've been
i've been gaming way too long to become
a pc gamer and wait for stuff so
god bless
[Laughter]
i wanna if if i'm excited for it i ain't
waiting for it
don't let full mo take me fomo will not
take me because phil domination
is that the formal will get me knowing
full well i'm not going to play that
game anytime soon yeah and attic is
going to play it right now like i know
he is facts facts facts like
yeah
it's been a minute we got it
it has been a minute
lessons though blesses
76 five dollars of attack king please
put these tcls in their place talking
about k versus 6k graphics all weekend
when we know none of them
and it's cool and you know what i say is
i don't have an 8k television upstairs
right so i'm i'm i'm real with you i
didn't run i just paid ten thousand i'm
not going back out sorry i don't have a
8k television right one of my tvs don't
do 120 hertz the other two do but i'm
not going to care for something i'm not
going to see my television upstairs
don't have adobe vision right so i'm not
going to champion something that i don't
have i if you see me retweet for
somebody this is for cod or it's for
sovereign it's for addict for for those
people that do have it right god bless
nothing but you playstation dudes don't
need it
[Laughter]
oh we got
beater five dollar super chat
phil spencer guessed on iop and he
reveals a new game but the terms were
you have to have you have to refer to
him as daddy the whole show
whoa whoa
adam
crazy
[Applause]
we'd never be able to live
[Music]
dad all right so no it's not gonna
happen
what i'm saying
i love you i listen i'm saying this
it could be a once in a lifetime
speculation now is there there's already
people in the community that say that we
just got to get one of them on the show
is that going to be a more natural
situation
we're doing it for the back no i don't
even i don't even call him uncle phil
like i hear people say uncle phil i've
been knocked buddy
you know what it is people don't
understand like i heard somebody say i
can't call no man dominus maximus you
know
you know why
because you feel lesser than yeah right
yeah but you know what he might dominate
me he's dominating the industry he's
maximum
he's maximizing maximizing the industry
and he's being golden while he's doing
it
he's not dominating king
maximizing kings
maximizing everybody out even that was
super poor
you know yeah you got a yellow pole yes
at the same time people don't know you
can say that to a man yeah earn those
titles title like like you're doing it
like the romans where they'd be like
like a test something such
exactly
right you call julius caesar yeah great
one and this that in a third come on man
give that man this title all right so i
guess the lords ain't doing it
no we're not doing it
i like the disgust with attic though
that's the question i like
it wasn't about yeah
not at all
anyway see me i won't be here so i'm
continuing to choose a chance yeah with
that wig for chat with ray with chris
today
there we go iron mike five dollar super
chat jesus i see what you've done for
the halo big team battle flight and i
want that for me
a lot of fun did that with attic up in
there
there we have a beater once again five
dollar super chat love the show off
topic tell us your own personal
paranormal creepy story you experienced
oh want me to tell you
yeah go ahead and wait because i was
just wondering
we got to get check it out i got a
couple yeah i'm gonna give you this one
right
so when i'm buying this house
i'm looking at different houses i'm
going i'm going i'm going
now when we go upstairs there's an attic
that's completely furnished right
has walk-in closets beautiful beautiful
but there's one little creepy door
one little creepy door you open the door
it's carpet the top is not finished
so when when when when the real estate
agent is showing me she's like yeah you
gotta um finish this part over there
they didn't finish this part
i'm like cool
now we put in bids
for a couple of houses right
as we walking down the steps we don't
close the creepy door
we don't close it i'm gonna tell you
this is the creepy part of the house
right i don't give a hell what nobody
said this is the creepy part of the
house close the door
as we walking down the steps i'm the
last one
the door creep open
oh
oh oh hell no oh check it out check it
out check it out
that moment that moment i knew
that the lady was going to accept our
bed
you know i knew it in my heart in my
heart i knew it right so you know what
that's a cake feeding situation that's
when you retracted it right there no no
no no i took that i took that because
the price was right
we had the price is right right now i'm
doing what i did no idea
no monster can get in there i put every
last you'll see that box right there
yeah that's a little box that's a little
box for a statue
that joins packed all the way up so if a
monster in there like this
[Laughter]
okay so hold on let me give my story
okay because
so i don't know you remember cog when we
were in elementary school
every every uh thanksgiving i would go
play baseball in puerto rico like over
over thanksgiving break like we would go
as we had an all-star team that would go
over there and we would play their
awesome movie
and so the yeah
so we would go and there was one year
that we had we had games with a
particular like town that it was just
difficult for people to travel to in the
day so we stayed in the in the town okay
and so there was really no hotels a
small town we stayed in an old church oh
no
and so the church the upstairs part of
the church had like
whatever where the priest used to stay
whatever
so this place looked
straight up like something out of a
horror movie it was just a bunch of like
like like
very basic like bunks and beds the
showers there was really no light it was
only like natural light so we got there
and we would get the after dark every
night right
so it was
you would just hear things in the middle
of the night
yeah the i heard screaming oh no i got
to go home yeah
and so
we would get there every evening and
there was like four or five of us kids
there and then our parents were there
was the time i was when this happened i
was like 11.
11 12.
um and i was like nah i can't we can't
stay here
we're going to be all right
and i'm just like we were there for
three days and it was the most
terrifying three days of my life because
i've never ever
you know you you hear things you know
you get spooked after you watch scary
movies when you're young and whatever
it's your mind playing tricks on you
this was the first time i was in the
situation and i couldn't go nowhere
i'm stuck i'm like yo take me to
grandma's house whatever come get me no
it's too far i can't take you you never
make it to the game
so bro
never never again and i remember the
following year
my pops was like all right no we're
gonna make sure nobody has to stay there
i lived in an actual haunted house oh my
god talk to me talk to me let's go
nah that's going too much of that stuff
that that that's what our other podcast
is for you i think
my whole house was haunted not my addict
all right so tell me something that
happened that made you afraid
cold spots in the house i mean i i've
seen i've seen ghosts in the house
situation tell me about that yeah
i woke up in the middle of the night and
i saw uh
well i heard a noise
because it was a two-story house and i
walked in the other room
and i thought it was my mom i was like
13 14 and
i saw i saw someone like look like
looking out the window upstairs so i
thought i was like like i didn't say
nothing because like you know you don't
just naturally just talk to someone when
i just woke up so i go downstairs and
and then i and then i i my mom's on the
couch and i'm like oh i was like
who's upstairs
you're the only ones here and i'm like
oh and i went upstairs and
you went upstairs you went back
here where else am i going not there
to the car something like that
that's just one of them i've heard like
people i've heard scratches in the bay
attic before i got heard
the random sounds basement yeah i i've
i've
stopped
i've literally had stuff go missing
before like
so you guys taking stuff
no like like i told you i got i got
multiple different situations but i'm
going to give you the reason [ __ ] let's
go
cause this man i'm super chatted
is just simple like when you just random
scratching ran i always have like these
random
creaks from the kitchen and to this day
i can't explain what the source is and
when i go to where the sound is near the
refrigerator whatever i then it stops it
stops i don't know what it is like so
it's like for me like i'm not the
paranormal dude but i clearly cannot
explain
why
at a specific time not even a specific
time just random you know what i'm
saying i don't know
physically see anything nope
you just heard and went to the source
that's crazy because i'm not going to
the source i'm not ever going to trust
me i'm black black
i'm
like in that house we had like nine 10
people die
oh no
yeah we we had like um
like a possession that was in that house
oh
yeah it was one of those like we can't
my great grandfather bought the [ __ ]
like back in the day
[Laughter]
you talking about your family
since family
yeah well no the the
one of them the possession thing was the
first thing and that was before the
house was bought right but then i had a
great grandfather that died in it i had
a couple cousins that died in them all
right so my situation is different my
situation is not a lineage right so
y'all seeing the different privilege
right yeah
so he has a lineage of the house and and
and situations happen and then one
percent that possession i was in the
brother
so good my man made it so no i refused i
refused to move back in the house it was
thank you like the the the city pretty
much made our family tear it down like
it was getting that kind of reputation
it was just we got to write a we got to
write
like it was getting so bad that like
people were vandalizing it and they were
seeing [ __ ] and they were wrong
okay so somebody asked that's that's a
crazy super chat you got the best out of
it yes yes now we're not going to do
this for every super chat it gives us 35
stars
that we have um
[Music]
hold on let's say we gave you 145 super
chat how y'all gonna call time in the
best co-op shooter the last two
generations come on chad y'all need to
get with the time oh hey king boo
forte first of all where was you last
week oh you know i needed you last week
i thought it was gonna be fun you didn't
do it thank you
what else to get there we got tyson
buhajo now i'm sorry if i butchered that
one um eight dollar super chat we are
lucky daddy phil came along and put down
magic the timeout and gave his 23
studios their allowance
daddy
you call him dominus
and first off
why is people in the attic show
commenting crystal d in there
they come here and watch you and they go
over they get a little bit more of you
they can bring you
over there
crystal d man
let's get these super chats we gotta get
this show going come on yeah
yo it's good you're like you know what's
funny you're not this pushy like right
you're like but they're just going
forward
i don't even get my intro
alone cox and mo was like we're gonna
finish fast yeah i'm like we're gonna
get a nice
three to four hours back on it exactly
exactly anyway
so we got mick fury or mike fury i don't
know how you pronounce it mick fury five
thousand shout out to you guys for
allowing us to be messy or in my case be
a total menace and y'all chats salute
question king is gladiator your favorite
movie oh my god with that person um
glad no you um
what's the what's the one with um
when you look at troy
achilles is such a beast
when he said
when the movie started off and the guy
said you wake up and achilles is laying
in bed with a bunch of women and i'm
saying that's a good thing but that's
him that's how you do
that's my joint um so
he tells the little kid tells them
they're asking for you they're calling
for you he wasn't on the field with the
dudes so the cat the boss looked back
like where's this dude get my best dude
the little boy goes over to him and
tells him it's the biggest guy i've ever
seen
i wouldn't fight him
and he looked at the little boy butt
naked and said
they won't remember that's why they
won't remember your name fireballs i
remember that class
in that moment right there
that's when that movie was a hit for me
but anyway
yeah
all of that all that five that's
so what else we got okay then we have uh
faisal assange two dollars i need a
movie version of sob story premise
there's nothing scarier than a holy
place that feels like it's menacing
no
raiden blade five pound super chat sorry
but i will always say the occasions are
the bravest people on the planet the
occasions are the bravest people on the
planet hell to swim with the sharks and
play with pythons i've never seen stuff
myself that's crazy
then we got b lou with the five dollars
shout out to the lords love the guest
shows but my favorites when it's just
y'all keep killing it
yeah we're bringing that back once a
month top of that at least at least yeah
we got to bring it back to just the laws
and cog need to break continue
then we have j.w as a shell five dollar
super chat
maybe crystal d can make a game off for
your story
then we got big up 20 super chat still
convinced microsoft is acquiring band
dynamical scarlet nexus announced at
their tgs presentation the color of
sarah bonds outfit she wore oh my god
that's the logo dynamical announced a
day later too
he had taken shoes on it's happening
he was wearing harangue's guard
yep you guys are being a little
ridiculous
let me tell you um a lot of what you saw
in the tokyo gaming show
the clothes that was picked was picked
for a reason
i'm sure they were for the eastern oh
you gotta get to that topic it has
nothing to do with her and what her
thing okay yeah
then we have a hustle and motivate oh my
dude they didn't know i was a member for
12 months time really flies i beat halo
reach last night no doubt with my homies
and oh boy that story is awesome yes i
love halos
yeah there are a lot of scary stories
over there are we caught up yes all
right and yeah and finally finally
there's this dude that hosts the show
that's been trying to get his intro off
lord cognito gave me ninja guy that guy
um yeah so defining duke went down shout
out to maddie we had one up on ultimate
and we were just talking about the
crystal dynamics giant and then
we had the amazing jeff grubb pulled up
so i was i was very happy for him to
pull up after the events of twitter
shout out to college shout out to david
jeffrey shout out to jeff grubb but uh
gaming one japanese yeah jeffrey school
jeffrey school yeah i love that guy yeah
but yeah like i said it was good uh
great show that should be uh free 99
going up on last stand media if you
didn't well if you wanted to wait that
was up on wednesday
last word no last word uh almost
r-i-p-e's computer the boy done spilled
water into the top of his towel
no
flooding you're on his piece you know
it's crazy next to your computer down
here you know what's crazy for someone
that is so like pc orientated and so
like cautious on pc about just why is
that water so close to your pc
yeah listen lesson learned i mean i
thought we we i mean shout out to thomas
no he survived what a one no never
saying like it's like less than one that
that's like that's like electronics 101.
and somebody might say no king you
popping bottles
my pc is over here on the side i'll pop
the bottles over it's probably it's one
of those situations perfect placement
you know unfortunately the perfect
placement in the perfect spill and it
just yeah his joint was flooded with the
gpu he had the 30 90 joint
and he took the yeah he took he had to
take it all apart the 3 000 yeah he had
the wild joint he had to take it all
apart get the rubbing alcohol have the
fan on it 24 hour but the car survived
every everything survived
everything so
yes
i i was i was talking to cognito and he
was like yeah you smell some water oh
he'll be fine he's like no addict like
he spilt like one of those big shaker
waters and i'm like what's like
the whole joint but shout out to him
we'll hopefully uh we're gonna have tom
warren back shout out to him that was
the guess he was so cool about the
situation but yeah for me on games wise
it's been phoenix point just downloaded
that on game pass very happy
very hard actually how do you like that
oh i love it it's all right there
yeah it's the origin it's the original
x-com creator
son's favorite
that he made um yeah he he's now made
his own joint attic he's been playing it
for a while crazy fighting so it's been
on pc for a while but now the console
version is out absolutely love it the
controls
oh
yeah suited suited for controller
perfectly like very easy they got the
nice tutorial they got a lot of things a
little xbox calm down dude a little zoom
up little asp little aspects of it if
you're an extra fan you're all the way
in
question yes can i do can i use a mouse
and keyboard i believe so
i believe so i think i saw it in a
technical description but i don't i
don't want to confirm officially but i
believe so
okay yeah so you got that and then um
yeah obviously halo will get into it and
then that's the story he's been late
shout out to crow it's been crazy but
look we got to get into business he's
pushing yes because we haven't started a
topic
you usually have a guest that gives you
an hour worth of day time and and
now he pushing that yeah
this
i care about your life
[Music]
very blessed to have some amazing
writers super talented very competitive
the best in the business the best in the
business as king says it as i say uh
internationally it's a true story yeah a
lot of flavor a lot of passion we're
very blessed so look it's time to
celebrate one particular scribe who has
gone above and beyond
you already
actually um you know you know of him you
know of him but um yeah he has some
great pop culture pieces um definitely
the lord of uh so how are we so coding i
was butchered
sweet goodness
there you go i was gonna give it a
little bit he's been killing it with the
guys you know so we are proud to present
september's lord dizzy
lognet scribe of the month to sister's
assistant sir chris
jones let's go to see you in there
what's going on man shout out to the c
unit sadly he could not accept his award
he had to work today but he said to
shout him out he would definitely try to
be in the realm another time but brother
you killed it you've been on fire
shout out to the lords that are on on
lognet yes doing double duty yes you
know he couldn't be here to accept his
roses
but because he's working these guys are
working overtime please go to log net
right now
go to gaming.net and go check out some
of these pieces go check out some of
these reviews go check out some of these
walkthroughs these guys are actually
really putting it down if you haven't
been to longneck please go right now and
go check your stuff out yeah yeah yeah
so shout out to chris he would put it
down he's one of our uh draft picks he
the boy would go hard man he's like yo
yeah he was actually down he didn't win
to vote for a couple times i'm like bro
it's competitive out here you know i
told him but rookie in his third one so
he did his thing so salute to him and
solve we got some business to take care
of yes sir you know it's that time of
month again um once again i'm doubling
up because uh last month we didn't have
our free day so i don't like taking time
away from guests you know um so i would
like to do it on this this episode so uh
moving forward we hope to have at least
one episode a month where it's just us
so that we can make sure we give you all
the proper respect and the time so we're
going to get into these double giveaways
so we're going to start with the
september and october 10 gift card
giveaway
oh 10 gift cards in the building and the
first ten dollar gift card goes to
[Music]
polybius
shout out to him
sound really roman yeah yeah i really
wrote it
that's what else we got
all right now the second ten dollar gift
card goes to
no doubt so let's get into this 20 gift
card giveaway
september giveaway goes to
[Music]
oh no we're rolling that one again
oh a fine young gentleman by the name of
brian that's all i said
shout out to him that's that's the bride
[Music]
that bag is being dropped off everybody
getting what they deserve
all right 20 super chat for october
not super jet 20 gift card giveaway for
october goes to
super swan 117.
the 117 version let's go
no doubt all right now let's get into
this trip right now um whatchamacallit
um subscribers do we need to join the
realm to get the next next emo addict
could pull us up like like 18 yeah
because we just got one oh by the way
little man
it's live should be in there y'all yeah
man
shout out to graphic guards i'm working
with deniro panero on uh the 10k shirts
yes sir um so that stuff is coming along
right now but you see a little man throw
that little man up in there that series
ass throw that up in there if y'all got
it let me know there we go there we go
put a little man up there little man
it's his day
little man
delilah she's shaking my head
why she's shaking her head that
why are you not feeling the power of
little man
blue man doing this thing
she affected it
what she thought she did
she did it okay
out there punched above his weight
that's a bad bet okay no doubt all right
hold on one moment got out to dilla's
next
new video that he put up which is really
good about the new stuff that's coming
to xbox okay
fantastic all right let's go now it's on
to the drip let's go get the drift
t spring giveaway for september 2021
and the first one goes to
the well we lost you there [ __ ] oh
oh hey okay
there you go oh i think i beat okay
sorry don't don't don't watch you're
going to be beating me sometimes i'll
get too loud yeah shout out to sure
bikes the incipit ghost oh
big shout out to the ghost no doubt
speak to the ghost slow-mo say what's
the purpose of bribing if i don't win
anywhere
[Laughter]
you got to play destiny sir
there you go
all right and the final giveaway for the
month of october teespring let's go and
the winner is portrait
rick davis aka butch this this
this gentleman we had the pleasure of
meeting at the last stand event
oh okay okay okay
yeah yeah
i remember now i'm like yes i remember
him yeah salute there yeah
big shout out to rick uh everybody i
have your information for the most part
if i don't i will i will get at you and
try to find you um and get you your your
your prizes yeah brian please put your
first and last name
yeah brian i'm sorry i cannot get you
that you don't
yeah impossible to find people to find
him right
get it
together yourself a little bit running
halo infinite better than my high-end pc
for some odd reason
a little bit outside
he's strong in the face so anyway let's
get to the poll and then we can finally
start you want to let me let me get
these uh
firepower super chat i was in church
doing a sleepover spiritual things but
having a dream about snakes and the
pastor head with the body of a snake and
i woke up told mom and left
i feel you fearless nothing scarier than
a holy place that is menacing nah yeah
um
all right yes then we got jw as a still
5. yo ilp any of you have a rag with
chloroform on it that i can't borrow
whoa whoa what are we doing there is a
turtleneck wearing sony zealot in the
chat that i need to deal with oh no we
don't do that here
what are you going to do with him
look we don't need to get subpoenaed
anywhere so uh keep your uh keep your
thoughts to yourself
sir anyway continue
there we go let's put the crest in the
chat for lord metroid welcome to the
realm sir repping that samus iran i know
i'm sure
friday is is kind of bittersweet because
it's supposed to be the the end of sam
saran's story so oh man i don't know
all right lucius augustus five dollars
of a chat fraud alert on cog he's just
trying to get some time in on halo
infinite shout out to the ilp shout out
to colin hashtag concerned dd
yeah he had a discord heavy man he'd be
at every um
defining duke chat too salute to him i'm
not trying to rush for hey
so
i wasn't able to do um legion of doom
this week on friday
that time back
what else we got yeah we got gaming
forte remember for 22 months oh homie
wow dang it's almost been two years
happy for all your success you guys
helped me more than you know in my
day-to-day life hashtag salute lawrence
thank you my brother helped you in the
um destiny too
and i just got a shout out splendiferous
deedee lee with the crystal d
wow
extra extra
there we are hold on a second i want to
make sure i don't get jumped which i i
probably will okay we got wandering
dutch with the 10 bounce 10 pound super
chat shout out to the lords that halo
infinite btb is the real deal fire
little man and big man playing beautiful
man big fish
no doubt
drawing tj five dollars attack good
morning lords hope you have an amazing
day like
what's up with the ball remember that
whatever
yeah that's that philly all right we
good hold on i say no it jumped me a
little bit so give me one more i see
rate and blade with the two points yeah
we got brett bingham ten dollars it's
not that it's not that reason i think
they're buying bandai namco king it's
been their actual business activity that
they've made me think they're being
acquired the last year of band dynamic
goals business activity is sus
they're not
no doubt no doubt you can take that one
from him
right now
again fire double fire
wandering dutch
and then you got raven blade let me get
up two pounds that's who i was talking
about talking about wandering dutch that
day okay raiden blade two pounds from
chat attic and cog no work today halo
infinite okay trying to get us all
okay
get smoke five dollar super chat time
marvel's avengers game pass edition also
october stack the game releases what are
the lord's most anticipated games for
october all right so i'll jump in oh
marvel avengers game edition is super
fire the fact that it comes with all the
dlc like that
october stacked with great wait wait
wait wait time out time don't don't
don't gloss over that because i heard a
dude go at me because i retweeted that
and i gave a shout out to phil dominus
maximus really expensive
in about that uh marvel uh wrenches is
coming to game pass yeah and hopefully
it'll give it to new life yeah but they
told me it was in playstation now
okay before them i don't know i don't
know oh but it was though let me tell
you what it was
for you guys that are frauds
this is for
you
we eat fine over here
we good over here yeah you're saying
they don't they no they don't that was
the playstation version playstation 4.
mm-hmm
they don't get the trimmings
so imagine you going to somebody's house
for thanksgiving and they give you rice
and dry turkey and say see you later
we get the trimmings over here we get
the stuffing
the gravy
with the mashed potatoes we get the
macaroni let's get all of that over here
so i do apologize if y'all thought it
was the same weird he really doesn't
apologize
to kids questions sorry no let's go it's
good to go so it's october stack which
are my my anticipated gamers are back
for blood because um
yeah what you gonna get delayed out of
october now right um
because it was battlefield but then that
got pushed that's delayed out yeah yeah
so now yeah it's back for blood kid
that's why i got what about y'all can't
want to know that's it back for blood
metroid
um
nothing really in october i can think of
i'm not really i've never i wasn't
really an uh that fed guy a left 4 dead
guy at all gotcha i think far cry 6
looks promising um and you know phoenix
we don't talk
about that but
phoenix phoenix point scenes seems
pretty solid too
so yeah i i think that's that that's
mine phoenix point because like phoenix
point
i've really enjoyed the xcom franchise
and you know
i think in terms of you know quality and
the amount of gameplay i can get out of
a game phoenix point would be the one i
i didn't expect
actually game pass to have so many rpgs
yeah in the beginning
this is absolutely nuts and the shooter
aspect of it is crazy but um
to go to my most anticipated for this
month yeah
it has to probably be
a game that i didn't expect which one
that came out
that i'm having too much fun with
because mighty goose
shout out
all the time
i think it was something else i said
yeah cool uh real quick cheney
uh sony needs to patent the ability to
put ps5 games in ps now xbox just gives
it to you phil dma spencer
it's it's yeah when they were talking
about smart delivery everybody thought
it was uh like a gadget a gimmick you
know because we heard of blast master
processing and all this other stuff we
heard of fast ssds and all this other
stuff and you know certain things are
gimmicks going in but this is really
engineering foresight going forward to
bring the lineage forward so when you
purchase one thing it actually scales to
the best thing
and that's that's value for the customer
i know sometimes we don't get the the
the best but you we get the shorten the
stick but this is actually really good
stuff that we're getting i really
appreciate it no doubt no doubt so we
all good stuff yes we hit this poll so
look man last week paul results in the
people spoken to the question with the
recent announcement of the initiative
partnering with crystal dynamics we're
not saying the other thing oh perfect
talk how confident are you on the
development of the game moving forward
the winner at 68
of the vote was very confident
initiative studio head already had
previous relationships with the thing
we're not gonna say to make great games
studios outsource every day beat
coming in at second place at 22 percent
of the vote was i don't care but why is
it square getting that smoke though
about studios you know letting go and
the last place that only eight percent
of the vote was not confident it's a red
flag if microsoft quadruple a studio has
to enlist help from a triple a studio
shout out to all the lords who
participated in the road lord king they
are in agreement with you they're very
confident about um the whole situation
with initiative
uh was it an all-natural situation sir
all natty yeah i just want to make sure
it was all natural situation
shout out to daryl gallagher shout out
to dale galaga making things happen over
there
anyway so look we got to get into these
topics it is that time
one hour in and we finally talked about
stuff so um yeah
halo infinite yo big team battle flight
aka
beta is out vader boys stand up let's
get to it
who has been rocking i'm gonna assume
not king
king
and that's the only reason why i didn't
try a big team because i was going to
try a big team so it's whatever no doubt
so ada who's the beta boy what's up
how are we feeling
i'm not the biggest fan of when it comes
to big team battle in the first place i
like more of arena but it it was fun
it's just you know i i don't like
having so many like lines of sight open
on me at all times like a lot of those
big maps are like really wide open yeah
and um i i i like more like
corner shooting than i like
because i can't stand the sniper in halo
because it's so accurate and they can
pop my head off anywhere so like i've
always hated
that gun being like really really
effective and on those big maps that gun
is really really effective mm-hmm now
you seem to be having fun on on we had
three modes we had the uh the capture
points almost like controlling destiny
then we had the capture of the flag and
then the regular straight up kill so but
it seemed like you was low with that
capture the flag though well i i it's i
don't mind playing it it's just it's not
my preferred pl
mode like right it's like you know it's
you're like you're a slayer dude
yeah no it's not even
i don't mind any of the game modes like
but when it comes to
like the actual modes i prefer that
classic arena 4v4 yeah
because
yeah i'm just not a big fan of like
eight people fighting over vehicles it's
just it gets so messy on there and then
everywhere i turn around getting shot at
three or four different directions like
this
that was yellow they did have a bad
fight in the clips and put the clips up
i don't sound like that
i mean i was playing with friends too
like you would never catch me in that
mode by myself no i get that like that's
why after like i left that i never
booted the halo infinite beta back up
because it's just like
i have no interest in that like i've
never been a big team battle guy
no no i didn't even i think i probably
played 10 war zone matches the entire
halo 5.
how many you said 10.
like like 10 matches the entire time hey
what five was out but what about that
was like okay
that was their version of um
a big team back big team battle yeah it
was yeah it's a little bit different it
was different but yeah but for sure that
was what they had in turn in lieu of
regular big team battle yeah yeah no i
think before i pass this off i was going
to say like what about just like how the
game looked how
how it ran what you thought so now it
ran fine i mean i don't think the game
like i personally think halo 5 looks
better
but you know i i don't i think it's more
like art wise
in terms of the most but
you know it ran fine like you know i saw
people complaining about like the
performance on pc yeah so this is why i
can't deal with that pc stuff because
it's like look like at the end of the
day
they're making that game for like
mad different
like yeah like and then they got to deal
with you know maybe you have a different
cpu like i'm not dealing with none of
that drivers like you know what king
guess what happened king what i clicked
the a button on the series x and it
worked fine right
yeah it's just like look like i get it
the pc is the is the best place to play
but it's like look like it's not the
most convenient by far and i'm not
trying to deal with all that nonsense i
just want to play my game question
that's all you said something about it
um
halo 5 looking better
that's my issue like
so all right you played halo 5's
multiplayer and you played a lot of it
right
and now seeing this
you said it looked better
what do you mean like graphically speed
wise uh feel i just think like
aesthetically it looks like okay
yeah and brad said they have to twerk
the uh tweak the the time to kill no
they don't
have the target they have to twerk the
time to kill it
i don't i don't think they have to mess
with that at all i think the time to
kill is perfect yeah like if you want
quicker time to kill go play call of
duty right
like there's a reason that the time to
kill is the way it is in halos because
you got a shield
right you know it's not one of those
things where you know in the time it
takes to kill you
in halo you could kill three people in
call of duty yeah
and there's a reason for that that's why
a lot of people don't get really upset
when it comes to being killed a lot of
the times because
a lot of the times if you're better than
the other person you have enough time as
long as you don't try to run there's a
lot of people that try to run in halo
instead of halo's design where if you
start taking damage you turn around and
fight you don't run right right
you don't be a sucker
how the halo
uh the the halo jump happened
is because the headshot sponges
no
headshot sponges like no i didn't get no
issue like that man
like the br i was three three hits man
three click three three shots they they
they're out
no doubt no doubt shot oh shout out to
bg in the building he said the mag was
better in previous halos
yeah it was but you know what that can
we agree you know peach maybe that mag
was a little broken in previously
slo-mo says don't give them excuses no
look i'm definitely not giving them
excuses i'm just telling you where i
play i got that issue
listen slow-mo plays the division let's
go oh damn
jesus yeah you had to go like that so so
man did you get a chance to get
unfortunately i think i didn't get my
game on but
i'll comment okay maybe maybe later
today is it still on right yeah it
should still be another day for uh
sunday but look i'll jump because i
think but let me tell you real quick
what i did see right through this video
i watched a lot of videos um okay
the physics are there and for me when it
comes to halo physics
yeah you can do whatever you want you
know halo you could you throw a grenade
and like you if you throw a grenade
uphill it's gonna come back downhill and
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna do
something wild and it's gonna cause a
chain reaction of things to happen and
for me that's halo right it gives halo
there's a weight to halo that other
games first-person shooters don't have
right yeah and and i saw all of that
i saw wild stuff i saw people doing
crazy stuff with the grappling hook
right oh the sandbox is crazy the
sandbox is what halo range is easy but
this is
greater than i've ever seen yeah i'm on
a sand box level
so i agree with addict on the way it
looks because from the beginning i was
like
it took a step backwards because they
wanted to do that classic thing which i
don't necessarily agree with i get it
but i don't necessarily agree with
but if they have that feel down because
halo 5 felt good didn't necessarily feel
like classic halo right
it was still that thing about like the
physics weren't necessarily the same and
it's for me halo is physics right it's
always it always has been and to me they
they have that down to a t right so i'm
excited to play it
i'm gonna be real with you guys man like
i think after playing this as long as
they don't make any drastic changes i
think they can relatively get get caught
uh get halo back to some relevancy of
what it used to be
clearly was because i feel like halo
wasn't amazing amazing back then like
god like when it come to first person
shooters just had very few like
competition fortnite apex you know call
of duty's starting to come back to a lot
of point but i do feel like it could be
one of those contenders like i i really
have fun you say that
one of those i kind of agree with you
because it's like it feels first of all
we haven't seen it in a while so we
missed it right and then the way the
stars are aligning
you know with obviously the situation
with activision and you know their whole
thing in the building you know their
accounts the accusations whatever and
from you know a lot of people you know
not super thrilled so far for what i'm
hearing about vanguard so far
then we just heard shout out to grub we
had him on uh defining duke the early
world on the street about battlefield
ain't
ain't sp
peachy so i was just like where and that
threw me and maddie off because we was
like word like we he again it's early
it's alpha things can change but the
initial impression is wakana so it is to
your point attic it is feeling like it
is being set up for halo to execute and
for the most part what we're seeing is
people are enjoy really enjoying
themselves playing multiplayer again the
biggest thing i'm worried about is just
the content at launch that's the biggest
thing i'm worried about like because
it's just like
i know
how these type of service games react
and i and i'm not saying it's right or
wrong
because i do feel like if you went to
people back in the day and asked them
you know would you prefer to play your
favorite game
for six months or prefer like a ct's
approach where you know maybe it's not a
huge with the content at the very
beginning but you'll be playing this
game guaranteed if you love this game in
a year two years from now would you
prefer that approach would you prefer
them to just go to it next straight to
the next project you know what i'm
saying right and and i think you know
it's slippery slope with that kind of
logic and that kind of you know uh area
but i i'm kind of leaning towards the
the
just for these multiplayer type of games
i'm leaning more towards the service
games because the games like destiny we
see that this works right it's like sure
some a lot of games as in the majority
of them doesn't come out with a whole
lot of content at launch
but i feel like
it's better overall for the for the
health of the game in the end because
look what you see at cds for all we know
they could have put all that time and
see thieves into a game that they
thought the community oh no no doubt but
because they they made it the way they
did they did the the
the path the way they did they made the
game the community wanted not the game
they thought the community wanted i'm
not saying that type of service works
for everything because it doesn't right
but i am saying that you know there are
a lot of cases where it has worked out
extremely well for the actual game yeah
they came out with that white well sea
of thieves is an example i mean
obviously when when it first came out
apex legends is yeah like it wasn't
feature heavy and it was a lot of room
for improvement but as we see now see if
these is killing it like as king used to
say
the billions
the billions and the billions you know
just because you don't like something
doesn't mean right that the masses
which i'm guilty of because i wasn't a
fan per se of it and to see where it's
at and i think again we talked with matt
we pulled up the concurrent numbers just
on steve malone it was over the ten
thousand mark and that was just that
shout out to um ben the mayor he he
plays that religiously they have a
strong community on the other platforms
it's it's going it's going well for them
so to your point yeah i mean i don't
personally like
when all the features are not there and
launch i'm still gonna i don't want them
to get into that habit but
for the long term of the game as long as
the foundation is solid and then they
continue to iterate and continue to
improve but see that's where you have to
see if the consumer likes the product
that you have
right so you give them
the basic what your premise is like
that's what apex was apex
first and then built on top of the
premise right it's like i said it's a
slippery slope because at the end of the
day you could be making a game that no
one wants but you don't know it because
you're not giving a massive amount of
people i think that we they need to
take advantage of preview programs more
than they do
see these should have been in the
preview program it should have been a
lot more of these service games needs to
be reduced because you're you're being a
beta board so
you know
they they are using you to determine
whether
they they're using you to determine how
this game is designed how this game is
and i think if you are being in this
type of program something like the
preview program you definitely
like it's not a service game obviously
but that game is what it is because of
two years of
of preview access right that game is
formulated by
the community around it and there's just
no way in a game like this
you you need that input like forget
about the secrecy forget about you know
obviously story stuff you can keep you
know close to the chest but everything
else about the gameplay yeah you got to
put it out there as soon as possible
it's just the it's the only way because
it doesn't matter that it's out there
already people know what it is and just
the person who's in there from day one
has been playing it forever already it's
it matters that it's good and has
lasting power right
and the lasting powers when it comes to
halo it's going to be why do people
continue to play halo
three months on right
we'll see we'll see i'll jump into that
king step away for a second um yeah look
you know the the multiplayer to me
obviously shout out to patrick ray we
had in the realm from 3 4 3 seeing
director you know
oh no now you back you better give it
back to you and um look i just felt it
it just it was so smooth
when i first launched i was just like
how the engine
felt good everything looked good it was
just a very crisp experience you know
what i'm saying it's from that there was
a bunch of delilah hd to chat she helped
us out there was a bug that we
experienced on console which is like it
wouldn't let us switch weapons in the
beginning was weird but then she said
you just put your control back to the
default she she definitely she saved us
because i was about to go away i was
about to go in but live shout out to the
hd girl women gaming she was oh no it's
a known glitch or whatever so we fixed
that but what's that
look
it's what i think what it is for me
it's a couple of things the weapons are
great
the sandbox is great it feels fun the
grappling hook changes the game yeah i
saw somebody put a video up of we do
have spiderman yes xbox bro it was
hilarious to me the the you know what
yeah
i was going to say that the funny thing
about that is like
people are going to play so differently
with that graph yeah when more people
get their hands on that they're creating
like it gets to the point where i care
about that grappling hook more than i
care about certain guns yeah yo it is
it's that power when someone's an
equipment yeah when someone starts to
shoot me i grapple onto something and
i'll grapple behind them
and
like they're gonna have to put that into
how they play halo like like not only
are they gonna have to worry about
getting those three shots with the br
but they're gonna have to worry about me
grappling behind them so question can
you grapple to them can you grapple
them things people are coming up with
besides the fact you could grapple
hijack and rob somebody out the whip
out the air out like it's all correct
then the repulsor yo the repulsor's
crazy too addict that repulsor joint
can you repose for rockets i seen i see
somebody post what's that joint the
skewer or something yo the the the sheer
possibilities in the sandbox
are endless and and you basically i'm
seeing people
you know i've seen the followers
thinking
i see you know i do is pull up in a
warhog you know what i'm saying back
whatever so they coming through i seen
a dude shoot you talk about that video
yes
grapple the the dude out of the joint
sit in the joint and then drive him to
his feet drive him to his people and
then drive them off the cliff cliff then
and use the grapple to climb back up
after he done
killed the team i was like yo the stuff
people are coming up with are out like
they got it
they got it on multiplayer man but okay
so okay so
my my question coming from an individual
and this is how god is good yeah god is
good always but this is how god is good
because god i trust me i was gonna go
back on my beta boy joint i was gonna
actually get up in there oh yeah
i'll wait for you i'm like let's go but
but
on friday my internet was out like i
said okay so i wasn't inside out now
yeah but it's back
yeah it's not out now that's right and
he don't give a little you should be a
beta boy right now right now is that
it's back you know we can debate is
still going after this yeah we
scarlet nexus
i'm back into that so i'm playing the
scarlet mess anyways um
all the stuff that i did see because i
try to look in pieces right and then i
try to listen to attic attic attic is
really my foremost halo dude yeah right
because he he explained to me that um
halo wars was going to be good for me
right
and it was
it was everything that he talked about
atriox and all that stuff and he gives
me the story behind the stuff like that
and i really thought i was a halo hate
until i actually i met addict so when i
asked him little things i really looked
to him
on certain things
i thought halo 5 looked the best
some dudes may say no we know about the
look it looked good it looked great
right so then going on to the next
systems what i want to know is anybody
that's been playing this on
the the og vcr that's a good question i
don't know how they experience this
that's a very question yeah
hold on put a one in the chat if it's
good put a two in the chat if it's bad
because i want to know what's your
experiences being that these
individuals decided
that at the detriment to the pc
they said we're going to work on this
version the most
we're going to give you the best version
that we can possibly give you if you're
on the ogx box because they're showing
you that we were committed to you this
way and i honestly believe that game was
the one that they stick they they they
staking the ground they said we're going
to give you the best version here
not the best version right best version
that the system can give you i give you
right right and if it was smooth and
stuff like that because i hear you guys
saying it's smooth when i got in the
control was good and i see the grappling
hook and stuff so it gives me hope for
when i actually get the game yeah that
is going to be fantastic i'm really
looking forward to campaign yeah and i
want the campaign to be and that's
visually appealing better that's what's
inside that's what's giving me hope is
the fact that
it plays so good it's so much i know
attic is not a big team battle guy but i
just look at look at all this stuff
going on right and i gotta shout the
engine you know i got lit oh
the what is it slipstream what is it
called y'all club space spaceship
slipstream whatever that y'all space is
what they got going on you know what i'm
saying and you could do the 120 hertz
it's looking crispy they have you come
on
yeah they've come a long way and the
thing too yo there's little things you
can notice like on the ground and um oh
the grass i was gonna get y'all though
i'm throwing both of y'all in the bushes
with the grass the way y'all was coming
at kane kane or whatever last week yeah
it's a different different different way
no we're not gonna do that yeah we gonna
do that oh yeah yeah dave was going
extra hard on this little indie game and
i i was looking at bushes
in halo infinity
immersion
let
yeah that was you know thank you i
walked into a bush and you know it did a
little harder
that was it
it needs to be on the same level as as
the game is there there was a little
wrestling in the bushes i've been seeing
a bunch of bush
animators
talking to somebody
ahead
all right so attic flame him and i'm
coming right behind you and we're gonna
do this with the flame let's go the
difference is between keenan and halo is
halo is not designed to have this art
style halo is not designed to be very
immersive halo was not designed to have
all the designs
i mean i'm just not going to speak like
clearly
at the end of the day we ain't going to
agree on that the type of art style that
that game had i was playing about art
style is that addict
it was it was that pixar art style
so pixars are required to have bushes
since we were doing spirits earlier
shout out to kader though so so so adam
is it does this really happen when are
you playing giant multiplayer games with
a whole bunch of people there they're
worrying about tree physics
i'm not gonna like go into into no we
gotta gotta get caught
i was just disappointed with the the
pixar artwork and it didn't it didn't
have a lot of detail in it that's all
like normal i didn't say the game was
bad i just said it wasn't for me
so what we're gonna do right since cog
like single player experience that he's
actually for xbox what we want cog to
say is when the single-player experience
over the show the game coming to xbox
the bush is moving
in the multiplayer joint we don't care
about the business because
he's trying to fight for our life but in
the single player when we taking the
time out we looking around at what's
those little dudes name
oh my god
what's those little dudes oh you're
talking about the rock
yeah the the rot
right so
when you're looking at the rock moving
all around and you're looking at all
this i really expect oh that old okay
shout out to slow moto for not frauding
15 days versus 1 000 plus devs and y'all
ain't got the same expectations for
visual shout out to slow mobile
he owned some shots
one of the best
but yeah look sandbox weapons
feels good you liked it though it loved
it loved it to the point where i want to
stop because i'm like yo i'm having so
much fun and it's a beta and i don't
want to really go extra until you know
you know i got to put a cap on that's
why i'm with you on that you don't want
to go too extra but it it's giving me
confidence that at the very minimum
the campaign
engine
right should be solid should be my own
thing because they they're going to be
judged right on that campaign yes yes
the multiplayer is free to play they can
build on it they can do the apex they
can do uh the fortnite they can do
whatever they can do the war zone type
of tears and get y'all in and and loot
box your pockets to death or whatever
they're going to do skin and stuff yeah
but then that single player
is where i'm going for oh no question no
question but here's the thing king
the multiplayer is looking like it's
catching fires like if you look at the
timelines or halo infinite no no
everybody's on it yeah that multiplayer
can literally be at 10 out of 10
if that single player oh yeah i agree
the game's getting a six out of ten i
agree
i agree shout out to uh shout out to e
with his computer
i love seeing messages for you do you
think they could release multiplayer
only if they had no reason to delay the
camera that that thing's coming in hot
or i mean hella high water it's both are
coming out we've got the vibe from from
343 there i just but what i'm saying is
this like i know i put you at it the
campaign has to i'm still not getting
them off the hook it has to hit but i
will say i've never seen this much love
this feel like going back to the halo 2
halo 3 days with the whole community
they're like yo this is it they were
there was a lot of hype that was for
halo 5's betas like
it's just not like this
people playing something new something
nah not like i got played in forever not
like i don't know man i i was big in the
halo communities you know there was a
lot of hype going in for that
in the community i'm talking about from
uh from a bigger
picture i've seen even playstation guys
i'm seeing people who don't normally
associate with xbox like throwing up
halo stuff and saying yo
you know what i knew you never tell you
what i knew
jez carter shout out to jez of the xbox
too not a halo dude bro he rips halo
every year he was like i hate it it's
the worst it's overrated it's this it's
that
he and there were rare yes they shot the
red xbox two the whole way he like you
know that short fire yo i love halo i
just can't stop having fun the sandbox
is over and i'm like yo but i'm not
convinced jazz
who is the notorious
here we go
here we go here we go
halo done right
i'll show you why a console can be
launched over here
that's what people are saying i don't
know halo's done and you know we don't
need a halo no we need a halo yes yes
we need it done right you know i see you
guys playing you don't think i wanted to
put my beta boy shirt back on and get
back out
we had to move the decimals for you he's
ready i was gonna just intimidate him
that's what i'm saying you trying to be
beyonce out there
i was trying the river
[Laughter]
sick and tired of destiny plans with
every fps to be like destiny go take
your behind
you know what's crazy slumber we ain't
even brought up destiny in a minute only
people bringing up destiny is you only
people i see bernie got destiny and uh
in the dps podcast is you yeah
destiny as much as the destiny haters
which is you
i know you why you want my boy like that
leave slow motor you can't be on them
like that no more no more put your
camera on i can listen
we not doing it shout out this little
slap back to him
kill him right now but that's the homie
but i can't hear you because i can't see
you i'm done but look great start can't
wait for the campaign if they i'll tell
you this though if they land this
campaign it's going to kill
it's going to kill and right now
you guys know right now they on a roll
yeah like they want to they
see first okay first forza comes in
it falls a hit like i know it's going to
hit paul yeah yeah we're pretty confused
playground don't miss playgrounds
then that means the last four or five
games has been
high
is on effect we're not going to act like
i know the the the the talk is no gay no
it's actually the games have been really
strong for the for this year they've
been on the streets obviously to
synchronize the uh metal gear
the um what you call it you're stupid
like similar to the depth store you know
what i'm saying yeah obviously okay you
want to throw def loop yes because it is
all right fine no doubt you can do that
look they they're on fire and then they
they're gonna end the year extreme if
this hits
that would be forza and halo to close
the that's a monster year that you can't
deny that like that's super quiet and
look one thing that you could say
whether you like it or not or if you're
a non-halo person
the news cycle with pop culture right
now with this beta is trending like i
see it you know what i'm saying so at
the end of the day look hey what halos
it just shows me that when halo's good
king like you said
the king is back when he when he's right
there's nothing different nothing
messing with it he's like a nas trap
yeah well he's eyes on his square yeah
but he on a square he got a good beat
and he
oh man you know what it is and that
that's what halo influences disease
it still is bad that's what we gotta get
to super chat what's next stop it
all right hold on one second did it yeah
it's a little
[Laughter]
all the songs two dollars to be jack
king ps now not a stable service like
the box just no this is not right
right
they work the same
[Music]
and we got raiden blade 2000 for chat
i'll join you guys later big team battle
doubt go down get that better get your
baby boy on you already know what it is
put your moves in
get in there then we got michael patton
five dollar super chat don't sleep on
unsighted those uh like those old hudson
soft games blaster master without the
car and adams family salute uncle fester
i saw that i looked at it and i said i'm
playing too much stuff right now and i'm
gonna download that and that other game
with the word um that game is ridiculous
my son is playing that right now
yeah is unsighted the one where it's
just it's it's all sound no is that the
other one that's another one um this
unsighted like he said looks like
blaster master it looks like um adam's
family
they really going back to the 16-bit
slash 32-bit era and only reason why i
say 32-bit because 32-bit started doing
stuff with the graphics that was
different that 16-bit couldn't do yeah
this is entrenched in 16-bit uh 60
frames per second really good stuff
no doubt no doubt
then we have
free eye kelly
it's funny he came back
chat halo infinite ain't it player base
gonna drop after the day game pass won't
be able to save it sony on a domination
train
called body karate
there for a minute man because he
disappeared so long man i thought you
know maybe he he really wasn't like he
was part of r kelly's team
what it was was
definitely came out and he got a taste
of microsoft
over there god bless have fun
um but yeah we're on a row you're right
oh you said playstation on the rope nah
stop playing yeah
let's go and plus yo um free to play uh
or kelly uh sorry brother like that's
huge it's not going anywhere especially
that we kind of know the multiplayer is
good for the most part then we got
two dollars
could could be server related like lag
etc
he said what you talking about
yeah the time to kill and some other
stuff
the pc lords have some
10 super chat went back to gears 5 to
check out dolby vision it's definitely a
game changer can't wait to see future
games that have dolby vision already
built then yeah yeah yeah
official official expound oh my gosh my
next tv will have it yeah tips
for cx users tips of the trade
it will not work right now because i
mean it will work on 4k 60. so put it to
see if you have 4k 120 hdr will still
initiate on the adobe vision supported
games so put it on 4k 60 spoke to the uh
the team what they're gonna do is
they're coming out with a firmware for
the cx and eventually it will have the
4k 120 dolby gaming version but yeah i
think the only one that has it off rip
right now is to what is it the c1 g1 the
newest the c1g yeah those got it off rip
but i'm telling you it's it's a nice
yeah shout out to delilah she got to see
where she she lit but like if you're a
cx a lot of people have the cx it's
common don't worry about it but just
throw the 4k 60 you're going to see it
and yeah adobe video so at 120 it's
going to enable just hdr 10. right h
because what happens is with the cx
you'll get that in the upper right hand
corner of the prompt like right no dolby
vision and i was freaking out i'm like
yo when i watch netflix and it's adobe
vision or disney it'll tell me i'm like
why isn't it telling me with psychonauts
and flight simulator and it's because
you have to put it to 60 for right now
there's a firmware they're working on a
firmware update with a manufacturer
let you laugh for that
what um
it's 4k 120 dolby vision it's a porsche
it's just that certain tvs i got a lot
of bandwidth that's a lot better tvs
oh c9 i'm sorry
why is the gamer know the c9 for mine
it looks like they're gonna the cx is
gonna be the cut off like it looks like
and then you don't see one don't don't
worry about it wise old game i ain't got
yeah we got jordan gregory five dollars
which that first time watching live love
the show thank you sir
and we got cedric h 20 super chat good
morning lord happy birthday that's crazy
jordan gregory good morning lawrence
have you seen halo clips involving the
grapple hook yes many many a life saved
falling off the edge of the world like
five
yeah i wonder if the halo team
we don't need spider-man we got our
wings okay i have a feeling they're
going to end up banning that grappling
hook in competitive play
but it it is just a pickup right yeah
it's a pick it's an issue
i'd rather have that pick up that that
grappling hook than the vr
it's that it's that i agree it's that
traffic because yeah
because the one of the problems with the
ar is you couldn't close the distance
quick enough
to make it relevant to be able to do
those battles with the br
but with the with the grappling code
just grapple right beside them you're
right up you're right aboard anything
now they're gonna have the disadvantage
because you're no longer so far away
from them now like you're right up on
them
and they're gonna have a hard time
actually clipping in on you then you
were just shooting them with the ar so
question once you initiate the grapple
right once you're you're being whatever
grapple to whatever
can you shoot in the middle of the
grapple or just when you land you gotta
wait
it's super fast though you hold that
bumper and then it it pulls and once you
release then you go back to
because i only see the one arm out i
don't know yeah
yeah
yeah so
i know it's like a big bionic commando
first person right it's that fire bro
yeah i think they tried it with the gun
shooting and probably found that it was
too old it's too old to be unbalanced
that's crazy because you kill them by
the time you get there
for instance like like for instance like
when it comes to
you're in like an outdoor area you can
actually grapple on to like rooftops and
stuff
so they so they they lose line inside of
you and if you're good enough with that
you have good uh you know awareness
filled awareness you know where they are
at all times but they have no idea where
you are because you keep grappling
everywhere yeah the factory
it's like it got a little zelda-y in
that regard that you could manipulate
and access pretty much parts of the map
that were never accessible in there yeah
it's that crazy immersive sim yeah
i saw him he was grappling on the tower
going around the tower
it was it was just crazy yeah what else
we got some chance though oh we got
bernard miller five dollar super chat
halo multiplayer is definitely fire we
know the game play is fire stanton just
just have to land the story shout out to
the lord salute no doubt
about that story man i'm worried about
that story i think he will i think they
would put uh buddy uh buddy dude in the
back
um he won't be a huge factor because
people keep telling me the human fact of
it y'all keep forgetting master chief as
a human
so yeah yeah i think yeah it's going to
be one of those things where it's like
it's it's that right people want to see
chief cortana they don't want to see
that other stuff you don't want to see
buddy do
there we go i don't
got it i don't think buddy dude is his
chain i think he has exactly the amount
that he had before
he came in there i don't think that that
chris uh that that you know he came in
there and changed the story
i think he might have came in and
changed the direction that they were
explaining stuff and probably was one of
the reasons the game got delayed to give
them more time but as far as like
changing
i i think i think it's what what king
said it's like look when he came in he's
like all right we know this dude's gonna
be in here just as much as he was before
i came here but we're not going to talk
about him at all
i'm going to keep him in the background
yeah
i remember them saying something like
he's an extension of the player
i think he's still in there just as much
as he was but they stopped talking about
yeah i think that's what i think that's
what i think i think they stopped
talking about but he gonna be in there
you're watching the show and me not
liking buddy
continue and i guess we find out what
happens to lock maybe yeah yeah cause
we've seen them toys
them toys
cheney five dollar super chat so what is
the prediction on what the new line will
be to say
xbox has no games from ps fans when halo
is good
if you're a fan boy you don't count it
like that you know what yeah
[Laughter]
i don't know
i don't think that there is going to be
a lack in that
i think it's gonna go eventually to xbox
doesn't have the games i wanna yeah
because
they're not gonna be able to say xbox
has no games entirely so they're gonna
have to like wing on that xbox doesn't
make nothing but the third person action
adventure over the shooter games and
those are the only games i want to play
like that's so i think that's where it's
going to go because i do think that
there is going to be a point like three
or four years mark my word now
the only place you're gonna be able to
play
the highest quality rpgs is the xbox and
i i think crazy yeah when these type of
when the fables comes out the elder
scrolls the the fallout
the star fills the
it felt alien to me using that xbox
controller yeah playing because it felt
so playstation yes like it really did
like if if you guys don't understand
like if you never had a playstation
before and you never played coding or
you never played uh um what's that other
game that you that you guys like uh that
sega makes um the rpg that you oh no
yakuza
the the japanese one
um and they just put it out for pc
whatever hotels are verizon no that's
not sega no okay but attic knows which
one i'm talking about um and then he
hoped if they brought sega that that
game would come over because it's
persona persona persona
they felt
so persona
when i was playing it
one thing i don't like about that game
is when you talk to the npcs in the
street they don't talk back to you
that's cool but
i i do like that how that game felt
right and it showed that
before xbox wouldn't have that game on
their platform correct so using that
xbox controller i really had to look
down at the controller and figure like
wow i'm actually playing this on my xbox
like the first time i played metal gear
on xbox i was like oh
yeah it felt like yeah like it's not
supposed to say i thought when tekken
we got um
deron james five dollars jack my son is
seven and a diehard fortnite player i
let him play halo and now he's hooked no
doubt absolutely yes i want to hear that
gaming forte five dollar super chat
slo-mo doesn't know what a great game is
unless he's slapped with it
content will be the one and only reason
halo will succeed destiny is still
better
oh you out here shooting
slow mo with the 5 out of the chat
return the division will rise again but
nah seriously forte brought up destiny
first i screenshot it for proof because
he ain't beat a game since 2018 wow
cause he's too busy playing division
stop playing oh yeah done i'm done
we got stitch five dollars just to let
everyone know 343 is giving every
platform the freedom to remap their
controller however you want with no
restrictions
and you know what's crazy man like
something like that should have been so
common like it's crazy that we're in
2021 and now
we're to the point where people are
going to let us like customize the way
our controller plays we should have had
this from the start like
something's like i obviously i'm not a
developer on how hard it is to do
something like that but it's just like
if the pc's been doing it this long why
is it took this long for the consoles to
get control over that kind of function
yeah i found that out when i
downloaded origami one
i started playing it i'm like oh
let me try to fix it around and i
noticed that you can do that i'm like no
yeah yeah i know i know the mapping
joint shout out xbox one with that that
you got uh was it rated blade we got
that one two pound super chat yes you
can shoot with the grappler no i think
you don't even get shot maybe
you can you can shot with the grappler
maybe maybe he could be maybe maybe
that's what it is elaborate is it can
you be shot probably can hit fire maybe
you can only hit fire because i don't
try to like shoot when i had it on yeah
i never thought yeah that makes sense so
uh let me see hold on i'm gonna throw
them back a little bit
we got
the trigger man
two dollar super chat
they will say xbox has his first half of
a game
yes there's no appealing to fanboys you
know it's just it's going to happen you
got to get warlord he loose yeah warlord
with the five dollars in the chat off
topic but shout out to lord addict's new
camera setup got him looking gorgeous
paws
so i've had two people ask me what
camera this is what camera is this i
don't know the sony's
this is this one here you go yeah there
you go guys
we've all had that camera for about a
month and a half
6 400 sorry i was going to say 94 yeah
oh bit yeah shout out to assemble and
everybody else for today everybody else
who helped us out
picking up picking this equipment yes
attic does look gorgeous
let me tell you something let me let me
tell you guys one thing
every time you super chat ain't nobody
buying no ferraris
ain't nobody buying anything crazy back
into the park what we're doing is we're
putting it on mics we're putting on
visuals we're putting on emotes yeah
we're putting it on
the the beginning
listen trust me when i don't
you guys make this podcast oh facts yep
in fact i don't know like if if the
chats notice that like my sounds don't
go up and down all the time it's cause
we bought a new mic that's right baby
got that sure
i bought a new mic so now like even when
i raise my voice to do my little uh you
know look my little comedy relief stuff
like it doesn't it doesn't blow you into
your drums yeah i'm kind of sad by that
because some of you some of you deserve
them ear drums broken out but you know
it is what it is shout out to clutch man
zero one final super chat game passes
the truth recompile surprise me okay
okay and then rate them blade again
right two pound super chat you can shoot
while grappling and beat down okay i
gotta try it i did not
do that so look we gotta move on get
this topic popping um yes look two parts
so we'll split it up let's start with
attic's part with uh tgs man what do you
want to talk about with tgs
i look okay because i know that some
people are going to disagree with me on
this
i i just i personally feel like
i get it you know people was like oh
addict you know they they gave
expectations to and they they did give
like you know scarlet nexus
um you know they they gave
that in game pass but and it is a big
game but like to me it's just like
i can't
completely 100 percent
feel like microsoft even cares about a
worldwide appeal
when they go to
pretty much japan's version of e3 with
this conference
and it's just like i you know i said it
on the attic show a couple weeks ago
i feel like they need to do better over
there man like like literally the
biggest announcement that i could say
besides the scarlet next that's a big
announcement yeah is the fact that
they're going to do better
on localization
and that's a big deal but
that should be something that is just
like that even shouldn't be newsworthy
like that should be something they're
doing automatically so the fact that
they had to go out there to like
we ain't announcing really anything to
appeal to you guys but we gonna make
sure the stuff we do have is in your
language like it just it just blows my
mind it's like look man like microsoft
you guys are never going to get over
there in any big way
unless you give them content that
appeals to to that content and then
people like oh you know attic but you
know they got the cds they got the halo
i'm like i'm gonna be real with you man
none of them care about that stuff at
all so you didn't care about the the
games that they brought over with
besides the um i thought i thought it
was cool but the thing is is i want i
want more uh i want dragon quest 12
coming you're gonna love that question
okay
i want all these games to come over here
but to me
unless you improve
the the mindset that across the the
world thinks then they're not going to
take this console seriously there is a
reason
that we don't get these big games these
big jrpgs because at the end of the day
you're showing up to their e3 conference
but it's like you're not even respecting
that that realm over there okay did you
know about the idea expo xbox program
they were doing with the indie
developers and all the japanese
developers that they tried
and that's cool and that is but it's
just like they doing that everywhere
else like imagine all right imagine
because they have a huge western appeal
right they have a lot of western
developers making western exclusives on
this side of the world
imagine them not having that right like
imagine you know when you go over there
imagine if it was flipped and all of
this stuff was only in japanese the
japanese appeal but it wasn't in the
western film we didn't have any
exclusives imagine how we would feel
that they would come to an e3 and
they've shown all their big stuff at the
tokyo game show like that's how they're
feeling they wonder why they don't sell
that many consoles over there because
you don't have anything for them to play
at all so like sure okay
no you're gonna have
you do have you're bringing games to
from you know from you know the the
scarlet nexus on the game pass so that's
cool and i'm sure a lot of them
appreciate that
but they're gonna need something to make
that more appealing to that service that
you can't get nowhere else okay like and
that that's my thing it's just like look
like
that's why i feel like i'm done of them
buying western studies i don't want them
buying anything else western
we've gotten plenty of western support
you need to start buying more
eastern support
feeling this was going to divert into
like
you know sega something right something
that appeals to that west that that
eastern audience okay that way what you
do
i think one of the reasons they don't
have anything for tgs is they don't have
any studios making those type of games
so they always have to reach out to the
third party support to show their stup
their stuff at that kind of stage but if
you had these studios right they had
original content that was making we
always bring up sega on this pocket
let's say that they eventually did end
up getting that that conglomerate like
now you can announce their games at the
tgs
and that would appeal to that audience
you understand that right now
i don't
i don't see how you can
realistically grow in audiences and
markets that you don't have anything in
terms of games that only appeal to that
audience and not necessarily only but a
game that appeals to mostly that
audience when you're not trying at all
in those audiences
i don't think that i think that not
trying at all is a bit harsh i can't let
that part go if if if they but 360 they
had lost odyssey they had new dragon
they tried in that demographic and the
360 didn't so amazing there but those
little bit of exclusives they got got
some kind of footprint there right but
see there hasn't been one
one exclusive besides maybe something
like like a dragon and that that was
that was no in japan that was on
playstation so you can't even count that
like to me it's just like look like you
can do all you want on game pass
but at the end of the day why would
someone buy an xbox when it's it's up in
the air if you're going to get dragon
quest 12 right why would someone buy an
xbox when you don't get no final
fantasies at this point right we don't
get seven we know it's 16 we don't get
14 we don't get seven remake two why
would you buy it when you don't even
know if you're getting the next persona
right why would you buy it when you know
i think it's a safe uh bet to say on
something like yakuza but we still don't
even know that right so it's just like
they guided you better on that thing man
we got
that's my biggest thing it's like like
you're not putting enough effort into
buying studios or even making studios
over there to have that exclusive
content why would a company over there
not like
it's so bad over their presence that
they had to show
what's the studio that bethesda owns uh
tango tango that's my part right there
tango studios have to
they had to have them to be like yo but
we don't need to
no no i'm not saying that they don't
need to show that i'm saying that's all
they have to show but
okay all right all right
so what what what what you're explaining
is they built like you said the western
market
they went really hard in the western
market to get this
uh solidified right
what i saw at the tgs show
was them going hard in stuff that i
wouldn't expect to be in game pass
remember game pass is the platform and
it was pushing the surface
like very heavy if you looked at its
surface was really pushed heavy in in
the commercials and stuff like that
so
them pushing these japanese rpgs these
games made from japanese studios and
highlighting the culture
remember they are present they are there
they are giving effort
playstation has built a relationship
with a lot of these companies early on
they cultivated that whole avenue they
made a pathway straight through so it's
a different thing when you call somebody
and you get a direct line to x y and z
and you can get these games onto your
platform so you get these games these
square enix games these final fantasy
games these stuff like that these games
that they're cultivating what microsoft
is doing is they're going and getting
square enix games
they're getting what they can right
they're pushing in areas that they can
you will highlight tango games you would
show them like listen we have a company
this is our partnership this is what
we're doing and we're going to work on
something else but i think scarlet nexus
changes a lot of things that goes on in
game pass remember game pass is the
platform right they're not trying to
sell that market an xbox yeah but
they're trying to that's what i was
going to say yeah right the the play to
me i got to jump in for a second right
um is besides that
what i thought was interesting is the
announcement of game streaming also
in japan that same day it's huge so i
think today
i felt i felt like the approach is what
what service i mean what kingston which
is not the console it's the platform
it's not and then you know cloud on top
of that but sorry sorry i don't give a
bad after no i i think you hit it out
the park with that and to me the play is
cloud the play is something small the
play is if you look at it
they don't create all these all these
japanese publishers don't create
japanese games for the japanese market
right they create japanese games to
appeal to the american market because
they're putting it on a playstation
right and the playstation doesn't have
the pool that it used to in japan the
playstation has that pool here and it
has that banned europe
right essentially they have because what
happened is japan is just is so portable
centric now
that's why to me the play is the
portability the cloud and more deals
with nintendo yeah
the thing is is we can't even say that
about sony these days like a lot of
their exclusives is is a western appeal
they're not eastern appeal anymore and i
feel like that's one of the key reasons
that the eastern market let they ask
right that's the thing because i think
it's just like their biggest game but
the
isn't necessarily in the type of game
anymore it's how you play it now but but
sony is still getting those games like
it's like we're backpacking
here but they're hitting i get that
we're backpedaling now we used to get
final fantasies we ain't got a final
fantasy in a minute fam well we got a
lot out of those final fantasy we're not
getting anything
yeah but see those those are time
exclusive deals
those are not going to break those
but sony goes out of their way to make
sure like that final fantasy deal is two
years all right i think it's coming to
epic game store sometime yeah middle of
next year yeah and still no xbox version
in sight so by that time the zeitgeist
stuff yeah he's already died
down when you get it by the time it gets
to game pass or xbox in any way shape or
form it it's like a an archive game it's
a legacy game right more often than not
people really want to play that game i'm
going to play elsewhere yeah i think
addict's frustration is and i understand
this point is to the to those big
blockbuster titles that xbox seems to be
missing i saw the show different right
and i saw it different too
from his from his aspect i see your
frustration i hear your frustration
but i can also um
put that to the side
right i can actually put my frustration
to the side and say that you guys are
trying in this area right yeah the
localization is huge a lot of times the
localization was wrong that's a huge
deal it was it was a problem huge deal
okay so when you're not trying to sell
somebody a console and you're trying to
sell them a subscription
it's a whole lot palaceable
fifteen dollars a month
ten dollars a month whatever they're
doing over there right right i don't
know the price uh
excuse me it's probably situation
but they have their cell phones
when you can turn your cell phone into a
gaming device or you can stream it to
your tv turn your tv into the same
gaming device that you're playing on
your console
that changes how you see it they was
trying to sell
surfaces
if they have laptops and moving laptops
they understand microsoft they
understand surface the duos duals you
know they're they're selling this
remember
xbox wants to reach that billion those
those those people
they're not going to do it by selling
xbox's physical xboxes to them i mean
and that's not even little man's not
even little not even
i mean you can always go to the
the
the youtube
comment section that that is for the
live stream and translate some of those
those comments and see what people are
saying because i'm telling you it it's
not as is is gravy as people be thinking
it's not like you know
they're not trying to reach that person
that's watching the live stream
they're not trying to reach that they're
trying to reach the comments
about that so at e3 they're not trying
to reach us no no let me let me explain
that's fan service i always say it's fan
service so
and tgs is fan service this is fan
service this is for us we are the trend
setters right when we talk to community
we're talking when people are watching
you do your show and you're giving your
fans you're telling them yo they did
this and they did that you are informing
the public
you are doing that but what they what
they're trying to do is have an app on a
tv an app on their phone when they ship
an app on their surface or their
computer when it ships and then they hit
the app like what's this over here
that's not even
the number one selling console in japan
we got to verify that okay even if that
is true on amazon though that it
relative to what to what yeah
and again i'm not i'm not knocking it
that's fantastic but when they say
you know the series s or xbox is selling
more than it ever has in japan there's a
caveat to that right
there was a week that it was literally
like i think they saw like 250 or some
stuff like that and it's like oh the
greatest yeah
and that's my thing it's like you know
people know i'm being stereotyped like
no man like like we can't see her and
act like the japanese support don't be
lacking like i got to play final fantasy
7 on my playstation i have had to play
persona on my playstation right i've had
to play all the dragon quests up to this
last one on my playstation and guess
what when i do play stuff on my xbox
it's two to three years after the damn
game
but this goes back yeah and i feel that
completely the thing about it is i i
honestly think phil and the team have
been trying but when it comes to that
it just seems playstation have cemented
those deals years in advance right they
don't care what the next
with the next final fantasy looks like
we're getting it even if it comes out
and it's a trash fire we got it first
and then we gotta be we gotta be real
about the elephant in the room which is
japanese companies dealing with other
japanese companies we can't act like you
know right microsoft just recently came
up on a list as far as from an
international standpoint of like on one
of the most hated lists right so you've
got that barrier with a region that
doesn't necessarily want to be receptive
to your products right let me let me
jump because this is great attic is
right i'm not he's right i'm not trying
to go at him like he is right xbox is
missing out on too many of these big
games where it's late in first but i'm
with sarvin king one i am seeing the
committed effort right the consistent
effort i told people the yakuza like a
dragon thing was huge at launch and
people wasn't paying me no money that's
why i went out supported i get mad
yeah xbox fans like yo i ain't playing
rand i love you right now though because
i'm mad at you and even play but um at
the end of the day you know it's one of
those things where i know that's
something you don't see when lost
judgment is coming out at the same time
that's something you don't see but i
think my biggest problem cog is i'm
tired of seeing a fire trailer on
something at the end of that trailer to
switch your playstation
wait let me finish let me i know how are
you at let me
this time
the reason why i'm a little bit more
confident this time with phil being in
the region is one
you got to look at first
if you don't respect the language of of
the country country that you're trying
to be in
you already that's so that's why again
the localization was one big to me these
are small building blocks to get to
where you need to be very big on respect
right that's respecting the culture you
ain't even got the games in the language
or the culture you you don't even need
to beat it then the second thing what i
like that they did they launched the
x-class i'm not saying oh my god just
because they got x-cloud that's the game
changer i'm not saying i'm just saying
we do know it's a mobile region a lot we
do know people playing a phone that
again a building block right the next
thing to me that nobody's talking about
is what idea xbox is doing with sarah
vaughn
where she
she was like look we are working with
japanese independent developers see to
me that's on the grass root level now
you get the next young star to debut his
joint the in-game pass that was my
second point okay like yeah
where playstation built these bonds with
konami
with um square and all these games if
you can build bonds with people that are
just starting you're giving somebody
they just started their new start you're
building them up from the bottom there's
a loyalty there it's it's crazy and the
fact that they put
listens
game pass somebody was hitting me up so
much because i was saying uh phil is the
the reason for gamepad soundbound does a
lot there and that's that's the next
topic there later but this idea of xbox
her in in this space
he's going to grow this space something
crazy and i think
grabbing them early like you said fresh
out
your game going put you in a spot like
i think that means a lot yeah that's
long
it's like the street team it's the
grassroots you have to well i like this
approach because you just can't go over
there in my opinion and just throw money
at the big game and they did that in the
360 generation i think yeah
uh just recently this past week i think
a week before
colin and the guys at sacred symbols got
a lot of flack for some stuff that they
said that was pretty good
yes yeah and and the thing about it is
they were talking about you know
not wanting xbox to keep purchasing
publishers per se because that takes a
lot of a lot of teams off the table
and what happens is depending on who you
go out especially if you go out and
purchase japanese publishers right if
you purchase the japanese publishers
there's going to be a lot of pushback
from the community on that it just will
be because again you're inherently
purchasing a publisher you're the
outsider on the surface exactly you're
you're muscling in one of the most hated
rated companies in in the world
internationally and not that necessarily
they deserve that
no i don't know you don't care
what i'm talking about
if the pushback is so bad yeah
that they can kill those franchises
we're gonna kill them
listen we're gonna cultivate them
cultivate that's what i think
they can they can be mad as you want you
could be all upset as you like mm-hmm
all right so you will still support i
don't care what it is you can say
whatever you want all these dudes that
was out there oh potential
you're still gonna buy
if if they purchase square enix
still going by you i don't care how you
feel you're gonna turn up your nose and
you still gonna buy it i know i will i
don't care i don't have any shame
so all that fake oh you're just trying
to speak your words into existence that
you don't want to happen all right but
when microsoft put that eye on your girl
she's going home with us
but listen
approach which is one grassroots the
indies location all that stuff right
then you do the game pass deals right
you get the third part of the launch and
get that on your service right you get
that popping i do agree with attic on
this though i do feel
there needs to be a commitment on a
studio level so that they to me the
bethesda thing gave them tango by proxy
right right but now they also need
a home-grown joint for themselves
and i'm with them on that yeah i think
that's my biggest thing it's like how do
you expect that market to take you
seriously when you're gonna have like a
studio in that market because that's
great
and i get it people want to count tango
and tango is a studio yeah but it's just
like to me it's just like they didn't go
out and buy tango by themselves
when you see the significance of what's
his name mikami on stage with phil and
that's in it's in the house right you
can't tell me that because he ain't got
shinji makami ain't got dumb
relationships in the region so if they
do decide oh no that that's definitely
right so my thing is i love the look of
them two on stage you get to talk about
the future talk about things they're
doing and then we let's talk about the
elephant in the room we all know let's
be honest kajima is common on some level
that's right so like it's it's they're
doing it it's just do we is it at the
level we want no we of course wanted to
be a slow it's a slow burn with this one
bro it's gonna take time it's good but i
like the fact that they are doing it i'm
talking about kojima game awards
[Music]
yeah i think when it comes to me man
it's just like i'm tired of that like
it's going to be a slow burn it's going
to be a slow break you got to get out
you've got something but it's been slow
burned for years
hold on i got to stop you know they
weren't doing it
like they were the other generations in
them wasn't even trying to cultivate it
the right way like coming from someone
like me that loves final fantasy i get
that like to finally get my hands on the
franchises oh i can finally play that on
xbox and the band they go on one day
like it's just like it's just
on the street is um let's let's get to
it
30 minutes but let's get to it all right
so let me set it up
for you so xbox game pass subscriptions
reach 30 million take two ceo says so uh
during the raps digital event the grill
why the name is the crail the grill 2021
take 2c ceo
zelnick said that xbox gamepad
subscribers reached the act of 30
million this comment was made during a
roundtable discussion that included phil
spencer and then on phil spoke he said
about game pass we think it's big uh
bringing more gamers to people but not
as a replacement for retail in fact we
had our biggest retail here in retail
ever last year with subscription we're
growing then zelnick continued to talk
to spencer and say hey the last time we
checked
we
got about 30 mil subs phil right
something like that however phil spencer
responded the last public number we
announced was 18 and he did smile when
he said that zelda then tried to course
correct he said yes more than 18 and
then he continued on talking about um
the service and try to grow it so look
this has been making the rounds you know
some people believe some people say no
king's got the chain up so king this
your topic you know there's 30 billion
all users that held the xbox at 50
million
when we know they went past that
yeah what what
like what king like for three years
people said that you know when you were
doing the topic i didn't talk at all
right
now so i can't okay like you don't
interrupt
so what we gonna do is chill out for a
second
so again
all right so i told you guys before when
i was telling you it was 26 your dudes
like really kings is crazy can you keep
me having that pie in the sky stuff
the biggest thing in that conversation
was we
yeah what's that about okay so now
take two right
the biggest the biggest thing in that
conversation was we already
[Laughter]
right
i don't ever say we
if we ain't involved
right you you with your girl your
outside and you say yeah we over here we
go
we
don't say hi
you don't say me
we didn't say you
[Laughter]
think about it right
you don't ever see we unless you booed
up
oh okay so now let's put that let's
place that we and and him saying 30
million mm-hmm why would you know that
number yes that i would agree cake
nobody i don't listen to your
foolishness
okay but that part is weird right why
would somebody know your income unless
they're not weed they're not booed up
somebody know what's inside your
refrigerator oh you know could you pass
me the um the grey poupon why would she
know the gray poupon is inside the
refrigerator
are you implying this is an all-natural
situation
i won't entertain like the the i do feel
like they would know that number because
like when microsoft goes to them for the
you know getting games on game pass i
feel like that is a metric that they're
gonna give them like we have this amount
of people in game pass you can reach
this amount of people especially being
take two with gta right i'm sure they're
they're updated daily about what game
passes until rush per second is crazy
um but again right
back at that part with the wii
and we're back at that 30 million
it's 30-plus
why is you why do we get these extra
numbers from you no it's 30 it's 30 plus
wow this is why we're an xbox player
you know you know why you know why it's
30 plus because it's making somebody mad
mm-hmm it's 30-plus it's making you mad
you're burning the cycle he was afraid
of this 30. the 30 was scaring the hell
out of you because you know when we hit
30 and see
i said
so i'm talking about me and xbox i'm
done
right people don't use we if they're not
associated with something remember what
i'm telling you okay and you guys are
afraid
is interesting it is interesting
but the the 30 million you don't all
right so let's get back to the magical
number of 30 million yes 30 million
change is a conversation for somebody
when you go to a developer that normally
doesn't mess with you and you say i got
30 million subscribers
and this is what we do day one when we
debut a game right day and date inside
game pass
we usually get at least 20 million to
view
20 million
and then we get a sale of probably four
or five million out of that 20 million
that scene a sale
so how can i get down with this like how
can i get this guaranteed bag that y'all
talking about because walking in the
door when you have big wallet
you guys know the dudes y'all dudes out
there with the black heart yeah when you
throw it on the table your conversation
is different right
yeah they treat me microsoft is throwing
the black card on the table
that conversation is different game pass
hit different now at 30 plus million
then it was hitting at 18.
see
a dude that's rich that's rolling in the
situation is always going to downplay
his pocket
phil said publicly
we stayed at 18 million right we'll tell
you what he's holding
but all right k can i push back on one
part i know where you're going
my only pushback is that if it is 30
plus that's a huge leap that's a huge
how would you
why would you not
hold on when did they mention that but
why would they remember the last
earnings call they didn't give the
number they didn't get enough so my
thing is everything was the last 18 when
they said it tell me when a minute man
it's been a mission it's like march
right yeah it's been a minute i just my
thing is i'm just trying to i understand
where you're going i'm just trying to
understand the logic if they did hit 30
why are you not yelling that boy
silence but that's a number to be proud
of that's a number to be like
no we don't we don't let the enemy know
what we're doing so when you but you're
gonna have to let somebody know at some
point with the earth oh yeah you do you
let the people that you know that you
gather into your side right bad boys
ain't gonna sit there yo real dudes
don't go around talking about i got 50
million
do that
real dudes don't have investors and
stuff they got to appeal to yeah but but
when you're talking to your investors
you don't give your investors the same
information that you give in the
feel that yeah but if you if you're
trying to continue to sell game pass
subscriptions and you just jumped 12
million in six months
i'm making it i'm making it there's a
press statement going on
out there
you mean they're to tell me they can
tell me how many rocks have been shot in
halo but they can't tell me how many
subscribers they have
but
listen if you're moving your situation
quietly
why are you gonna upset the apple car
why are you gonna open your mouth shut
up don't move your hand don't don't say
nothing to let the other dude know what
you're doing over here in this situation
uh oh this is hard yeah so i've been
driving after you i mean i think it's
closer to what grubbs speculated i think
it's in the 23 range and if we hit 25
i'm crazy
if we hit 25 by the end of the year
that's going to be amazing
i think i i because the thing if you
really think about it what big games
have there been to really push it
forward you have again all the small
stuff that's coming to game pass on a
monthly basis i'm with you i with you in
the chat i see what you say because
that's what i'm going to because
all those games are great i love those
games king loves those games but that's
not appealing you didn't respect me when
i said the millions you didn't respect
oh no you're right we did it
we left you i think we said things we
did listen when when phil get on that
stage at the game awards and hit you in
the mouth with the 31 or something crazy
mm-hmm then you're gonna be like okay
hold up hold up are you saying that it's
going to be at the video game awards
that he's going to announce i'm just
saying something big it's going to
happen i will say that if whatever
announcement does happen and that's why
i want to get up and give it back to you
is that you announce it like we know
halo before is going to move gabe right
and i think so right we know that's
gonna happen right so to me it's like
you do the splash then and you'd be like
yo and then you know we just dropped the
biggest racing that already we just
dropped halo but you know how did the
buzzwords be and then he's like down the
game pass that that's a great news
splash that's a great headline why don't
you release that information today um
horizon zero don't come out too
why don't you drop that information when
they drop a banger
and then why don't why we gotta bust
first for no reason i don't even think
it's about buzzing at first i just think
it's about investors like what addicts
said i just think it's about the timing
as to when you know they want to do the
press releases yeah and it's also not a
one-to-one comparison like
to come out at the same time that say
30-30 million subscribers no i feel you
but it it's on the game of the game
basis what you talking about
i said no i'm just saying like
it's not going to do anything for me i'm
saying like it's not going to move the
needle for me why because you got game
pass right right but the thing about it
is it's like all right
if i'm really into horizon zero dawn i
don't care 50 million on games yeah
they're not gonna care yeah they're not
gonna care so it has to be like a
one-to-one comparison for the same
product right and it's just not that so
to me
they'll say it when they're ready to say
it
yeah but i don't think they're there yet
i think the numbers are gonna get a nice
little bump come to holiday yeah come
forward agree with that come halo
why okay okay so this is this is for
solving uh-oh i re all right so god i
already know you yeah you are
conservative at heart yeah you know me
i'm always here
right you never put your chips in the
table yeah you're never pushing it
you've always been the dude that's out
front you outside
that dude yeah you're not that dude
attic attic is more of a maverick yes
right
i don't sometimes i don't know what he's
gonna do yeah
but he's bored with whatever he gonna do
he's a wild card yes right
sovereign does this thing
wants to believe but he's been beaten to
submission so much that saul
but in his mind his mind said yo don't
don't reach too high for the stars i
would love the last time i reached for
the stars they beat me back
i'm not gonna reach for the so you say
you're saying i shouldn't i shouldn't
because i i've been emotionally scarred
by xbox one this is what come on
thank you we both installed we kicked
them exactly
right and so for me i keep them at arm's
length you know what i'm saying i'm not
embracing you like what they need to do
to make you love them
what they need to see they already got
cod with baseball
yo he never in his wildest dream he made
your wildest dreams come true
that was that right so i was like who
did that for me who did that for me
listen
addicts while this dream came all those
uh what's those um kingdom hearts
wildest dreams what is your wildest
dream bro i'm so sick and tired of you
playing this i don't know what's wrong
with that they know haiti's over here
what do you need
i'm sorry i'm sorry no one could be new
to you when that was new to me two years
ago
it's just not the hobbies already had
that added listen yeah
[Music]
no man no i don't know i'm sorry i don't
know
it kicks off the king's point though
what's going to make you a believer with
it because you're on this nintendo wave
something crazy and it's nuts you're
watching this 480i crap the eyeballs
bleeding i want to know
exclusive partnership
or whatever some sort of partnership
with sega
and you bring back my old franchises
right okay so you need sega you need
sega
i need i need sega in some way shape or
form i don't need them
oh you got the direct line and again
no no no hold on hold on oh get the
glasses off
[Music]
pull that trigger because i'm sick and
tired of him people like him
saying they need something else and you
know the most all right
no i i'm the one from keeping us from
being a full-fledged yeah that's what
you're saying tom is responsible for
xbox not reaching the heights it needs
to reach listen
that say that they need to bring them
over your cousin's still it look addicts
said he went there one day the final
fantasy is gone your codes are still
there you are in trouble now sega's
coming and you gonna go right here
i've got a bad i've got a bad tracker
here for this bend the knee stuff so i'm
gonna bend the knee to the day by
seconds
you you want your undying feel to you
playing down the line crap
i'm done look we'll see what happens man
it is uh interesting how i feel they
didn't want to jump ahead of it they
were smiling i do agree with king it is
very interesting that uh strauss knows
anything about any number internally and
using terminology
i didn't catch him saying yeah we yeah
he did i i didn't even catch that i can
read the quote
no no no i'm not saying oh you just said
you didn't catch it i didn't catch him
saying it right like i didn't notice he
used the word the term we
so that that's interesting because i i'm
not not necessarily there with like him
knowing the game pass numbers because i
do think he would know something like
that but he definitely wouldn't have
used the word we that is weird like yeah
yeah i i think last he said he then
asked spencer
i think last time we checked we got
around 30 million subs phil right
something like that
is it very interesting verbiage by zelda
that's interesting look we like that toy
[Music]
yeah now let me get these super chats i
don't want them to go too wild and crazy
okay hold on let me scroll back a little
bit
uh come on man
jesus we had a couple read
what they want me to read so cool
yeah
okay lord the nature of the quote that
you just read oh okay yeah i got it i
got it
uh lord nader five dollar super chat
they launched xcloud on brazil and its
success all the servers are full so hey
xcloud is going to be
it's going to be there mm-hmm we got
heart cheney 5 super chat does sony make
any jrpgs aren't all their studios
western now does nintendo
the thing is is they don't have to
because they have those relations
microsoft doesn't have that all that
that that luxury that's true yeah if so
many banks on third parties why can't
xbox did sony do tgs
uh not really though they don't care for
fan service they ain't got the bread
let's go
family
shut that down
[Music]
i don't think you really know what the
eastern audience uh with the eastern
audience is you're a westerner what are
you saying what you're saying is a
stereotype i don't think
what what
why don't you go read some of the
comments section and translate some of
those and then come back and have this
conversation what's crazy to me is
what's his name joshua is that his thing
so you mean to tell me that me wanting
microsoft to show more japanese
role-playing games at a tgs is somehow
stereotyping a japanese market
put it down sit down joshua yeah i don't
i don't really know where the stereotype
is coming continue yourself then we got
phaseol double oh seven
4.49 pounds super chat when xbox reaches
a large number in asia then those devs
will think twice to skip xbox ecosystem
in the future that's always been to play
as soon as those numbers go up then the
conversation changes a little bit mm-hmm
now y'all see y'all thinking in old
metrics we're talking worldwide here
worldwide
then we got dwayne anderson five pound
super chat preach attic ps5 is at one
million units in japan you see
yeah not as powerful in japan as they
want and you are heating the whole
building
space
then we got black conflicts
let me let me let me address something
to the chat
youtube comment section is not a front
of wisdom bro so let me get this
straight
so joshua uh tells me i'm a westerner i
can't speak for the eastern part of the
world and i tell you to translate the
eastern part of the world's comments
and that don't make sense to you alvin
i'm just joking
i'm
there we go laughing is the cure five
dollars of attack king is right forget
the pushback microsoft needs to be
behemoth that they are that's what i
said i get it
then we have flame with the five dollar
super chat good afternoon fellas it's my
brother's birthday tomorrow can i get a
shout out for him got him a little man
oh
happy birthday
and we got bernard miller who's to say
tango won't have a thousand debs in six
months there's a is more than one way to
skin a cat yeah you know what it is
sometimes also we forget and when we
talk about one particular developer yes
how many teams they could have under
that underneath the belt yeah what a
face it could be multiple games love him
and makami together
it looked very nice i look very nice i'm
all about that but you see what you did
love is that they left together
yeah you know this isn't a partnership
you work for us
i already together i already had a
feeling something like that was gonna
happen just because like when you did
when he did the
the e3 uh thing when he was talking
about them like you know i'm sure he's
excited that you know all those studios
but
particular tango he brought up multiple
times because you know let's be real
here like they've never had a studio in
that part of the world so when he was
able to get it i'm sure you know he was
excited to work a little more closely
not just like as a second or third party
like i'm not bringing up that you know i
just want the thing about that that
that that whole thing is i just want
them to have their own studio there
and i want them and i want to see more
of these games that i have to play this
big bulky playstation that i can bench
press
i want to get off of this thing you know
diego said a good point right now i got
to read jacob's comment it says sony
nintendo are japanese bred and born
companies of course they're going to do
better in their native country that
applies to most every company that's
created natively there's a point there
yeah i get that but but look at
look at playstation in the states like
yeah
america
i mean they they made western content oh
yeah
europe yeah but i got a shout out barry
and persona with their what's up like
they just had charlatan on yes and sean
layton talked about when playstation
first uh dropped and how
it was a struggle to get the games over
there them to buy anything american when
they had their launch they were not
figuring he said the only game that they
were semi feeling was f1 he said and it
was because that has international
appeal but all those cool games like um
what's that destruction derby yeah
flocked over there so yeah they're
getting what it is is these dudes don't
they are new playstation dudes right
yeah right so they don't know they don't
know the struggle that sony had to go
because you know because ps1 ps1 was
very japanese yeah
that that that's that's the point i'm
bringing up is look like they've
struggled they struggled for a long time
but then when they started really
focusing on that with those western
games
but but like but once the uncharted two
hit once
those games
how easy is it for you to be better in
your home country than a foreigner like
what people are pissed off with
microsoft's
is
how is out how is playstation
outperforming you in your home territory
right it wouldn't be a problem but
because playstation was outperforming
them in japan that's not a problem
because that's expected
what i'm saying is the reason that
they're able to do that and the reason
they did it last generation is because
they had the best western type of games
they just did there was no denying that
the majority of their games
was above and beyond what i'm saying is
you can't have the opposite unless
microsoft invest over there
if that type of caliber game if there
have been part of the world if there had
been more parity in terms of the quality
of the game to western games like attic
says i think the numbers in the us would
be considerably closer close it's just
what it is it's like and at the end of
the day it took them time just like you
know it takes time and it's generational
it doesn't it's not going to be as quick
as you may want it but that it there
i'll just like that they work right
we're going too long with this we're
going to get
hold on a second i just copy paste in a
couple more
uh
then we got laughing is the cure once oh
well first of all no no no hold on
we got uh
baba yaga put the crust in the chat
[Laughter]
then we got laughing is the cure again
five dollars super chat i think game
pass is closer to 30 million and i think
phil was waiting to announce the game
past numbers in new games later this
year pgs let's hope let's hope
i think i think
thank you we need you as a regular panel
member
[Music]
you got the warlord one with the mark
this episode okay
with the who
yeah i think we missed a couple because
you got flying no no no my bad you you
your head don't know i think you're good
good continue yeah i know we had a lot
yeah no no i'm too far down you're good
you're good okay yeah then we got a
fat boy horror five pound
announcement will probably be at tgs at
tgs or i'm sorry tga the game awards or
the 20th anniversary no doubt yeah makes
sense that's still coming up then we
have alvin five dollar super chat they
went from 10 to 15 million last summer
with no new console or games and no one
was shocked now this is shocking
i don't think people realize how like i
always try to tell people why you know
what there's no games over there why are
you guys game pass is a huge entity that
a lot of people know especially on the
xbox brand doesn't give them enough
credit when it comes to game pass like
sure have they been a little bit dry in
terms of exclusive games on xbox yeah
but guess what you know why xbox people
in on twitter 24 7 talking about it
because they're doing nothing but
playing game pass games every month
that's keeping them busy
i feel like i feel that
uh raiden blade two pound super chat
there's always a new generation gamers
we remember sega okay okay like sega's
dead
feel like sega's just gone flame two
dollars super chat what did i wake up to
i guess
yeah he's gonna catch it he's catching
this off uh king is going at him joshua
found super chat
video game awards microsoft's to
announce they have 40 million uh-oh 40
in the building i wish that's the reason
he didn't say is he what because it
wasn't it wasn't low enough
then we got warlord 10 15 5
mark this episode as the one king took
the glasses off a moment in the culture
that we were all alive for classic
blessings
mark this day is the day
that phil looked at it and said
[Laughter]
king taking the shades off and speaking
apparently picked the wrong day to give
up on my edibles
how badly microsoft wants to get into
the japanese market i would not be
surprised if they bought two japanese
publishers
why not be published it can't be a
studio
i i think what it is is like a lot of
the most popular japanese they're owned
by publishers and i think that's why
people naturally go to that kind of lot
like it can be developers the right
developers it can even if they built
their own yeah and just poach people i
know that sounds really bad but you know
and we have splendiferous with the two
dollar super chat lord sav all right
has doubted the swami for the last time
listen
uh if you listen to this podcast 10
years from now you know that's not the
last time i'm gonna die
this is what we do baby this is what it
is and he has been to me this whole way
through yeah
you know it's funny how some people like
to turn the truth around
listen
listen playstation does it every day
baby
you got back compat really really you
did yeah
every year
hello for what what what did you get
back
it was like i think that was a
though it wasn't a wash because it was
some some fake
cod
nobody else
showed nobody else
jd gamer two dollar super attack king is
on the show
then we got nicholas b five dollar super
chat xbox is partnering with over 200
independent developers based in japan
through our id xbox listen yeah that's
gonna that's gonna bear some stuff
that's the one that's gonna bear fruit
that's the one you gotta look at you
partner with the you just gotta start on
the grassroots level man the mixtape
scene all the hottest rappers you gotta
get them that's how you doing good and
they got then this does my heart good
lord roughness with the firepower super
chat so microsoft comes out and tells us
different i will continue to believe
game pass is at 30 million subscribers
12 mil can easily switch from xbox live
get what xblg yes sir
blessings our games are gold yeah yeah
yeah shout out to boom in the chat y'all
shout out
double battle gaming me and boom was
talking yesterday shout out the boom
shout out to boom
then we have i believe fat boy horror
with the five pound super chat told you
lord swap me
so look man we gotta get into it it has
been fun solved this is you let's do a
kind of a quick hit because we all go
yeah let's go um in uh what was the
worst kept secret in all of gaming
sony has finally announced that they
have completed the purchase of bluepoint
studios and added them to the fold as a
playstation studio
uh bluepoint has obviously worked with
them in a second party capacity for a
very long time uh bringing over a lot of
the playstation classics uh upgrading
them kind of upresting them resolution
remastering them um with the latest game
being the demon souls remake for the ps5
and before that the shadow of the
colossus remake for the ps4
um what's interesting about this buy is
that apparently blue point is not going
to be doing that right at least at least
for the foreseeable future they're going
to be working on their own sort of
so
first off what do you guys think about
that right when you think about
obviously nix's king's heart working on
pc porsche
that's my heart
i hate i hate it but i love it i hate it
i like i hate it but i do love it it's
the funniest thing about it he never
heard of them before
the funny thing about this he didn't
know who the hell they were but when he
found out what they do
he was like
before you tasted chocolate i'm done and
then after you taste the chocolate that
was your hard work
so i didn't know about blue point and i
didn't know how much i needed them to
laugh that i knew that
that's my heart
nexus is crazy
they won't answer my quote i'm literally
trying to get merch from them so i just
buy i want them to wear it on the show
maybe i might need to reach out yeah
no they don't avoid it
so so what do you guys think about this
purchase and the scope of the other
purchase that they've had recently
obviously they uh picked up fire sprite
which is made up of people from sony
liverpool slash psygnosis oh you wipe
out fans wipe out and colony wars fans
will remember us diagnosis we got to
talk to cj grinnell i think he's
originally from
i believe so that liverpool area in that
studio but yeah continue yeah obviously
nexus like we talked about in house mark
so
what do you think about this and then
bringing them in the fold
not to bring forward games anymore but
to do their own thing it's kind of
i don't know like i don't really know
what playstation is thinking right now
because obviously i think they deserve
the shot 100 to make their own game
and if they hit with a brand new ip
that's just another banging ip and
they're stable but
it's a little it makes sense to purchase
obviously because they only really
purchase people that they they've had
relations long relationships with
but to see them allow that change and
not have purchased them for what they're
known for
is a little different so what do y'all
think let's get attic 600 in the chat
y'all hit that like button man it's
about 300 likes i really do that but
yeah please share it out hit that like
button y'all you know saying i do it all
the time you know you always do it i
never do it i got to do a better job of
that share it out yes please please
machine it [ __ ] is live y'all share this
live your cousin your brother your
sister your auntie
your grandma need this exactly so addy
we don't curse we don't curse so you
don't have to worry about
us making you look bad
you look crazy no doubt so adam what you
think man blue point games fire sprite
where were you watching doing big things
what's up i think they deserve to make
their own game but like part of me he's
like they do that so well
and then like i'm like sony's got so
much like are we confident that this was
said by someone from sony is this like
going to kind of oh you know you know
they said that they're they're next
they're working on original ip yep
confirmed by um uh lord herman
host and the head of blue point and then
yeah they're there so this is not gonna
be this new effort is not gonna be a
remake for their first joint it seems i
mean cool they deserve the shot they
deserve the purchase they do really good
work on uh demon souls kind of curious a
studio that's made so many different
varieties of genres what their actual
game that they first think is that's one
of the biggest questions i have you know
because they have proven that they can
make anything like literally anything
you can think about yes so i mean from
from demon souls to shadow of the
colossus like they are so probably one
of the most diverse
uh
studios out there because of how many of
a variety of different gameplay
okay okay let me ask a question then
like um i get it they have worked on
other people's stuff but you know the
same people saying that oh yeah i gotta
stop whoa
i'm sorry i'm sorry y'all gonna love me
in a second the same people saying that
or the same people are saying we have
nothing absolutely nothing to worry
about you know uh playground games
working on fable sure they have made
fantastic racing games but they've never
made any kind of rpg
are we supposed to like where is that
same logic well points only about 90
people about the size of the initiative
i don't know like is initiatives a trash
fire of a studio
we don't know we haven't received this
stuff i will i will agree that i i do
feel like i'm gonna let you know
sony should have kept them on the uh the
remake train because they do it so well
but i've always been one of those people
that's like
once you've proven yourself and once you
show fruit over and over again you
deserve your shot
and i i do feel like blue point has
gotten to the point where they deserve
their shot now the good thing about blue
point and uh you know
you know god forbid they this don't come
out hot
they can go back to making everyone
else's stuff again exactly
yeah we got to see
king you've been waiting
i'll be right back
so so
we all know
boo-boo been cleaning up and doing all
this stuff
when you gonna wife me where are you
gonna wife me
boo boo doing all this stuff
she's doing all the remakes
sitting there spitting
other over people other people verses
and i want to point out king that uh
blue point has seen mad other studios
being bought by them yeah like they were
sitting there like
like i've been here before them
i put out that classic uh nice hit i
remixed the knives did the remix
i put a new beat on it i spit line for
line i i gave him my oh what's up
they said he was like nah
what you gonna do you're gonna get back
over there and you're gonna go give me
that demon souls 3 again
and then they was like oh man you know
what you know what
i'm sick of this i'm leaving
they wasn't returning the phone calls
put old boy on block
and oh boy he called it was like yo
listen listen like you went over to the
house knocked on the door all right aye
aye
i'll make it official
she said but no listen daddy
you haven't allowed me to do my own
thing mm-hmm
i've been spitting everybody tracks
and and you know
oh boy no her freestyle trash
he knew her freestyle that's why she
ain't never get in the house but
nobody said
all right i'll give you that i'll give
you this one shot you can do this
and then you can go forward and we got
you
he wiped up brought him brought him on
the cheapest you been if ever brought on
the jeep been there forever he gave her
the track to do her own thing
you guys need to be fearful
for somebody
remember when cannabis came out the
battle rapper battle rapper battle
rapper battle rapper battle put our
album together and it was hot trash
this is gonna be a
remember that jesus christ first track
that that blue point never put out
myself
we're gonna see what's gonna happen now
it's good when you can see somebody
bored and you can remix it and put a
tree over here because it's looking nice
yo let's put a spoon in your field let's
do something
with the beat put a snare over there
put a snare here
like you'll do the shoulder pads nice i
like the shoulder pads because the
shoulder pads look nasty that's bad
i'ma tell you
y'all really don't know what you're
lacking you thought you got something
nice over here yeah when i talk about
this knicks and stuff i know what they
do
support your games over the pc i'm happy
that
this dude was taught literally remixing
old stuff
bringing it current not making movies
there's no potential for them to make
something hot just
no way
i don't know what they're capable of
but to be honest with you
every time i heard somebody doing a
cover
of somebody else's
i mean
[Music]
100 with king but it is one of those
things that's like all right you proved
you can make everyone else's stuff look
nice now let me see what you can do
we do gotta have that kind of energy but
i'm not gonna go with king be like oh
they're gonna make trash because they've
always known basically king acting like
they are whack ghost writers okay so
like like that you know what all right
remember the time we was in that ball
and we was we was watching the mma
joints
all right so we had the drink and it was
lit and we had that dude that was
singing there yes and he was doing the
cover stuff the cover stuff was lit
right every time he covered somebody
yes yes
when he sung his original stuff
time to take a second let me let me get
a picture
the only game that they developed
themselves was back in uh 20 2006
a psn game called blast factor and it
was i i don't i haven't seen how it was
received but it was notable because it
left it was it was the first
it was notable because it was what it
means 1080p 60 games
on the console
we about to we about the metacritic
score this [ __ ] what is it called last
blast
now
so y'all want to see how they album dip
so like what it is it's crazy we've been
a playstation founder we don't know
nothing about black people
we've been blasting
we don't know nothing about them
he's got a 68 medical
the quote-unquote playstation xbox
stitch
the 68 meter critic
and they got a cool 5.9 from iga
is that who sony just gave the keys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a hot cover they're a cover baby
and what they did was they turned that
covered band until opening that i want
to know if we're going to hit qrikets
i think they've had plenty of experience
since then that was mainly like jokes i
love how messy we are there we gotta go
dick
first games
i want to know what you did before
i am done with you
look let me jump this is hilarious oh
listen they got 16 y'all 16 studios in
the building now you know getting close
little 16. i'm a little magician
now but i mean you know the the buzzword
solve right now is organic growth yeah
and um ground up grassroots grassroots
center
look they do have we have to admit they
do have a history of like king said you
know they they go steady for a while
before they consider that you know they
say they you got to put that work out
you know what i'm saying so you know
they've had that relationship with them
they've done the demon so remake they
remake games fire they took king's point
they covered the illest cover ban in the
world done so at the end of the day
look you know they get the opportunity
to do it just to yes i was gonna say
just to clarify king you said they need
features to to be good right they need
features i i honestly think and be
honest with you when you're a cover
studio
you've been covering this stuff for so
long
okay so you see you're laughing at me
but anytime they you heard a game being
remade for playstation
get blue point yes yes yes everybody
said that right so am i wrong no no now
and now when they making their own stuff
i
guess i guess to me i see them working
on other people's stuff and doing so
well for it is giving them more
confidence
yeah look yeah i was gonna change the
bars
the thing why i like it is because of
good i gotta we had jason schreier in
the realm i gotta talk about that report
when the day's gone to join and they
told ben's studio now ben you ain't
getting another sequel you google work
on
last of us remake or whatever and help
out naughty dog whatever so the to me it
looks like this the fact that they are
allowed to make a new joint to me feels
that internally
herman and the team saw something that
they liked from them
she was gonna walk all she do right now
i know where you're going i know where
you're going i know but here's the thing
and again i gotta shut out the ground i
know i'm plugging be able to find it was
lit y'all i'm telling y'all it should be
up now
grub said a good point the reason why
we're seeing all of this acquisition is
from a financial standpoint
there's money allotted already
for acquisitions for this year
apparently after this quarter or
whatever in the next year that same
price it's gonna be like an extra five
percent that's huge on course so if
you're gonna buy
with that you have to buy now so there's
another thing is there's a rush for both
sony micros if you notice everybody's
buying yeah everybody even nintendo just
bought what is it the luigi mansion
dudes or whatever yeah they just but
they don't know about because the price
of the brick is going up next year yeah
yeah this is like inflation is going to
get inflammation yeah
you don't do that you said what you're
gonna do plus there's other vultures in
the water microsoft you know what i'm
saying you got to lock it in now you
know so that to me it's a combination of
what you said i i do agree that you can
there's a part i don't believe that she
was going to walk yeah i honestly
believe this gotta lock him down we
already know same thing with insomniac
right we know they had the past
relationship you lock them down to me
the key though besides i don't really
have fun with blue boys hilarious with
the cover band stuff you know but fire
sprite is interesting because fire
sprite
again like saul said those were the old
liverpool dudes a lot of them from that
you know what i'm saying i like them
dudes i like i like the wipeout series i
like your last one
like
it was all that they fought and they
were
not a studio under sony's banner well
get this because i didn't understand
that they was sony disbanded
this is a weird story they got disbanded
when they were sony liverpool or saudi
whatever they were right they were guys
as liverpool but they they liverpool
evolved out of psychonosis right right
you're right and then you know because i
thought a lot of that
that was part of that original obviously
not everybody is now being uh brought
back and it's fire sprite and the thing
i like about it is i'm on listen i got
to keep in the same energy you guys
kings say i'm always on microsoft about
hashtag just one you don't say i might
have to come up with hashtag just2
for um playstation
i want
multiplayer games on playstations
and that's what i like fire sprite seems
to be in that pocket with whatever
they're going to work on or whatever is
going to be there and i think at the end
of the day sony needs that because
that's the deficiency they got all the
greatest
you know over the shoulder they got mad
at that now the thing about that is they
would have to grow that studio right
become that because they i mean again
they did the room right they did the the
the astros playroom thing
um what the heck they did that other
game i forgot what it's called the the
it starts with the p the something um
yes they're not it doesn't seem like
they're built for that right so
it's they have to grow into that so i
don't even know it's weird i that's why
i said it's weird because
the purchases don't necessarily seem to
fit holes that they have sure say but
but then the way i look at it is like
this it's the i forgot the little studio
that they said is it buying now later no
but we're forgetting about what you're
gonna come up soon my next topic is the
vr aspect yes you know and they probably
go they have some some because i think
they've been in a bag on that too but
it's it's interesting i thought they was
well they need that yeah they do they're
pushing forward with the placement
playstation vr too
they need that no doubt perfect segway
if you're ready as i was going yeah
yeah let's see man it's that times cog
segment
[Laughter]
luck man
good boy
very disrespectful over the years
very disrespectful every time king talk
about that damn vr i roll my eyes
hey time everybody talk about vr
car got something slick to say
shout out to bill stilwell shout out to
the great wall shout out to you know the
lord of bat combat the lord of project x
cloud he was mixed reality for a while
now he's with oculus but um he would
come on i'll be like phil i ain't buying
it
you know what i think also remember that
time magazine joint where they had the
kid
it was remember that
that was palmer lucky oh god that was so
remember he you know he said some things
that people were not happy about and
then they wanted to disassociate him
completely from oculus the creator of it
i didn't like that image representing
the gaming community
with the feet out with the bare feet
with the chest and then i i ain't like
that man yeah yeah but i ain't got a
front so i got that quest too
so i'm like i finally set up the space
bomb
all right let's do this drawing whatever
we get it popping
king
i'm gonna tell you where they got me so
um so he started the joint and they like
you put a workbench in front of you
so first they had the little cube so you
got the cube you grabbed it you
manipulate i
did you insert the cartridge the
cartridge don't forget to get to where
they got
and i'm controlling the blimp all around
my space it's bumping into me and i was
like oh
i hate
the way they got me
why they had a robot come up to me and
was like yo what's up
he put his hands up
so the robot put his hands out and he
said they tell you to grab their hands
so why they grab your hands in the beat
drop and you get the deal
so what you're saying is that what
you're saying is that you know if if cog
ever not feeling uh man ask this man to
dance
[Laughter]
you doing to be i was like oh this is
this is crazy it's one of those things
where like when cogs started getting
real deep and dude he had to like make
sure nobody like you can't let nobody
see you there's a lot make sure that the
windows are closed
like nobody cares
what game did you play all right so the
further than this demo all right guys
episode
got me
right star wars immortal
okay question here oh question here so
when you walk into the cantina and you
look around when you see somebody see
their
and then i was like oh okay then like
darth vader dude you know what i'm
saying and then the thing that's crazy
about it is like the manipulation of
like you first you're like in the ship
you're flipping switches you're doing
all this stuff like you really in the
millennium you don't see the falcons you
know it says something alright cool so
you land out whatever whatever now the
only thing is like you gotta move
it it's not like a first person shooter
or whatever whatever you see like if you
see down the hall you gotta click click
and go and then it's gonna pull you
right okay you're on training whales
right right right but then you don't
want to vomit you don't want to do that
right where they got me though there's a
part where you brush out of jail
and you gotta scale the side of a
building and the robot you broke out
with like yo don't look down was like oh
yo
it makes me feel i was like oh i'm
holding on i'm holding i'm old you know
you know what i'm saying so if i ain't
go front dead i got to drink with the
lightsaber
that i would do without doing the um the
blocking the bullets they always get in
the fight i am not going to front the
one to one
the um
they have advanced vr in such a sense
down that like i played v alpha way back
when it was you know very kind of
primitive the advancements are i ain't
going fronts i mean shout out to i want
to shout out a couple of people um shout
out to mag shout out to x cops uh gamer
xg and my man um dan from umbrella they
gave me a whole list of games yeah i got
half life out i did the joint with the
virtual desktop where um you could
control your joint bro they got that
netflix in the yeah i ain't going front
like christopher hart
did you did you sit in the movie theater
and watch it yeah oh god yes tell me it
ain't the area's best feeling it's the
best feeling joint like i'm not it to
the point and shout out to christopher
because i know he goes hard for vr i
ain't going up front when psvr i'm i'm
i'm in well the only reason why
i'm a little skeptical on they join even
though i think their joint will be
superior in the eye ratio yeah and it'll
probably superior to the question
yeah but
the tether the untethered yeah it got to
be untethered because that's what the
quest tube does no but the playstation
isn't enough it won't be it's going to
mean
it's going to be the power of the
playstation 5 power here
yeah that that kind of that kind of
breaks the immersion from data wireless
is confirmed no it's confirmed
they told it right off get your
expectations out the bushes
well i can respect that thing at least
they told it they have to tell you
what's up you know what you what you can
expect
i thought it would be wireless i was
geared up for it to be wireless and then
i found out that it's wired and i was
just like yeah but you know and you know
the crazy thing is over valve is coming
out with their wireless yeah i heard
they're coming out with a new truck but
look i got a shout out man i'm a
believer i'm definitely it bro when you
you like this is the future like this is
this is like to me it's criminal that
the matrix doesn't have a game in this
because i think that's the perfect joint
but no it might be might be in december
yeah with the new movie whatever
whatever but yeah
man i had a fantastic time salute to
question two so besides that what did
you play do you play beat saber i got oh
yeah
right now it's just beat saber
um there's a
not to make it too political this is a
wonderful day guys
i put addict in a vr situation and had a
good time with him at uh pax and
it's like for cog to do this this is a
huge thing he knows how much i'm a hater
i was a hater like it wasn't it wasn't
it's just again
you know the the advancements how i need
wireless though that is the key with the
quest 2 is the wireless aspect
it's fine
it's the it's the future of gaming on
some level now it's not going to be for
everyone and i get that i totally died
for me yes we understand it's not for
you you're saying but they got me i'm
definitely what was your question song
i just
tell me when you play half-life alex
that's all yeah i know i'm saving that
for last
because everyone's saying that's the
generational but oh yeah that's what i
say not to get political
but there's a joint where it's like um
it's called like i am a man and there's
another one it's like traveling while
black and they kind of put you in the
situation and then when you look at you
know i'm saying depending on your race
whether you're off you're not you know
and it gives you depictions of like
experiences of what yeah put you in yeah
you're more sensitive some more
situations the immersion is just next
level and and again i got that it's
there's a please play resident evil
resident evil i'm picking up resume when
it comes out oh four yeah soon yeah four
is coming out soon play seven play seven
seven is available no no no i'm not
doing that because i mean no matter of
fact i'm gonna try it but everyone told
me it is the scariest thing known to me
did they push seven out off the
playstation
seven is off of playstation now i
thought it was
because it was just a playstation thing
at first i don't know i thought it was
available
no i don't know no no no i don't know it
was originally just a psvr thing i don't
know if they if they ported it to what
they did yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like like ready play
with this works too bone words yeah get
them into that fair phobia they trying
to get you in there yeah they try to get
out i was always scared when darth vader
was when they pull up i'm like yo fam
you in my phone like
chill like you nah but like i said it's
really cool man it's really cool salute
that's what's up gotta be the knee but
that's all i gotta do just get about
here
hold on let's make sure i got this last
one yeah make fury back okay let me roll
back a little bit just vamp for a second
all right so i can do the pole while i
do that
new ilp poll this week this is a good i
had a time to good i figured addict
would be feisty today with all the
recent announcements by xbox at tgs2021
were you satisfied with microsoft's
presence at the event the choices
a
no
they are not doing enough in the region
they need to be more aggressive and not
excluded excluding bigger games plus
another studio in japan it was funny i
didn't even talk to addicts but i do
[Music]
yes they are making steady long-term
moves with japanese game pass games id
at xbox xcloud and localization or c i
don't care y'all all gonna bend the knee
when kojima pulls up in that xbox japan
realm salute everybody in the realm pull
it up the poll will go up actually the
post should be up soon and get the vote
and then solve let me know when you're
ready
ready to go no doubt no doubt
we got tyson buhajo again if i massacred
that i'm sorry um eight dollar super
chat back for blood grounded update age
of empires four forza horizon five and
halo for the rest of the year and that
doesn't include everything that'll be in
game pass yeah it's a lot
then we have the wise old gamer five
dollar super chat sony asking blue point
to make their own game it's like paying
for a street work and then asking her to
make dinner
it might be good but not before yo
we doing into a house that was kind of
crazy i was kind of crazy that was a
hatred to a housewife you know what he's
doing that's correct and that never
fails me never fails
he he's super chat to wilmie tweets
he's he's like the living meme account
exactly
there we got four eyes malone five
dollars if you chat y'all gonna hold
shorty blue point to the fire because of
her past uh
if i know your past hell yeah
oh like
come on
look man all i'll say is you know
there's a lot of scenarios that you
can't really go too too much into but
blue point's history out there people
talking
it's in the streets out there
come on come back
oh man we got mick fury
fury 5 super chat i talked about that in
a video even netflix just acquired his
first studio in high school that's right
studio makers of oxenfree exactly
so cog is right everyone is buying yes
it is cuffing seasons
yeah you have to otherwise the price go
up yeah you know yeah netflix might buy
your sony mm-hmm
uh-oh
that's it
alright cool
[Music]
he's like he's
um probably here in the next two weeks
we're going to do another one of those
uh q and a sessions yes uh so when we're
going to play chevrolet 2 yeah we got to
schedule that out i think that was the
ninth one next saturday
because we got the movement
we got there did you buy it
i i did not because uh they don't come
out till wednesday
what's up happened we're supposed to see
venom we didn't see venom yet oh this
week
they came out this week i don't know but
we were supposed to be i couldn't make
it yeah
so we figured we figured out what yeah
we definitely got to figure it out we'll
figure it out
anything any other announcements
uh no not really uh king wanted to know
how many members we needed for our next
uh yes thing
uh we need
17. okay so y'all know what to do ram
check that out also i want to say um we
got to get back to the if the run wanted
to participate in their patreon uh poll
questions remember we got to get better
that's fun and um yeah the other thing
obviously the 10k thank you look in the
description now y'all will see the uh
the team shop is there because we're
part of the 10k club so right in this
video right now just look below you can
click it'll take you right to the store
if you see something you like so that is
the new inc
implementation
what's up and keep in mind we uh me and
king are working together with uh which
ones uh which artist is doing this one
pinero
de niro yeah we are getting uh um
10k shirts
designed uh these will be a limited
thing it's like we're never gonna like
we are gonna have a limit on you know
how long you could buy these probably a
month once we get that because we don't
want to like swamp our stuff we got
let's say theoretically
a little bit we get like 20k we still
selling 10k shares kind of makes no
sense so
you know keep that in mind but we'll
keep you guys in check when that when i
go live and everything because we wanted
to have it well you know entirely
available already but yeah nerds but you
know the uh our concept is is different
and we have to work with people in their
schedule so yeah no doubt no doubt so
that's what we got realm enjoy your
sunday we will be back next week we out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign